Guten Morgen Andre. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Guten Morgen Andre. Guten Morgen Tim. Warst du eigentlich schon mal in der Schweiz?
Ja, ist aber schon eine Weile her. War's schön? Ja, da gab's Toblerone, wie da drüben eine riesengroße, leere Packung steht.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, die einhundertzweite Ausgabe und äh ja, wir begrüßen euch,
in unseren Anstrengungen hier irgendeinem Terminplan zu folgen, das,
mehr oder weniger gut. Besonders Linus ist da gerade so seine Problemchen, deswegen kann er heute nicht dabei sein. Das wird sich dann nächste Woche aber schon wieder geändert haben, aber ich begrüße, wie schon erwähnt, Andre
hallo.
Hallo, bin ja nicht zum ersten Mal hier.
Genau, du bist nicht zum ersten Mal hier, du kennst dich schon aus, muss ich dir nicht alles sagen. Das ist gut
Kannst du mir heute mal alles sagen? Ich habe nicht aufgepasst. Weil es war ja so viel los, es war Republika und äh überhaupt so Berlin war sehr aufgescheucht
Das bringt dann hier immer alle Terminlagen durcheinander
Aber so soll's ja auch sein, so oder so ist es auch äh auch ein Netz politisches äh Ghetto, der da gewesen. Oder werden wir da später nochmal drauf eingehen, denn äh heute haben wir nämlich ein
ja ein Gast und wir begrüßen hallo.
Guten Morgen.
Genau, hallo, du rufst uns jetzt an aus, aus der Schweiz und wo genau.
In der Nähe von Zürich. Ja.
In der Nähe von Zürich. Genau.
Du bist ähm ja, quasi so ähm netzpolitisch engagiert in der Schweiz. Kannst du mal vielleicht mal so aus deiner Perspektive sagen, wie?
Ja, ich bin eigentlich aktuell in zwei Organisationen äh beschäftigt. Das ist die eine ähm ist die Swiss Privacy Foundation, wo wir uns eher den,
Digitales Selbstverteidigungsworkshop anbieten und endliche Sache und die andere Sache ist die digitale Gesellschaft Schweiz, die hat ähm,
Zusammenhang mit der digitalen Gesellschaft in Deutschland. Also wir sind nicht organisatorisch oder so verbunden,
aber Teile natürlich ähnliche Themen, die wir bearbeiten. Wir verstehen uns aber eher anders,
Zusammenschluss von verschiedenen Organisationen, die sich im weiteren Sinne,
Netzpolitik, in der Schweiz widmen und stellen da eine Plattform, wenn man so will, zur Verfügung.
Wie lange gibt's diese Plattform schon?
Das ist seit elf.
Wo wir uns das erste Mal äh getroffen haben und das war zu einem Netzpolitik Synergietreffen,
und das gibt es noch immer, das findet halbjährlich statt, jeweils im Frühjahr und im Herbst.
Das war so kurz nach der öffentlichen Bekanntgabe der Deutschland, oder? Habt ihr euch auch an dem Namen angelehnt.
Das Treffen war schon vorher.
Die die Gründung von Schweizern, die offizielle Benennung.
Das war zur gleichen Zeit.
Mhm. Also ihr seid quasi äh im selben Kontext unterwegs, aber es ist halt jetzt äh rechtlich äh organisatorisch nicht miteinander verbunden.
Nein, wir sind nicht verbunden. Es gibt lose Kontakte. Man tauscht sich aus, ähm hin und wieder mal, aber das ist jetzt nichts, was ähm institutionalisiert wäre oder regelmäßig stattfinden würde.
Mhm. Gib uns doch mal,
Ein Überblick, weil wir haben jetzt hier in den letzten zwei Jahren viel über die netzpolitische Lage und den Aktivismus in Deutschland gesprochen selbstverständlich. Das ist natürlich hier unser
primär Fokus über Thomas Luninger haben wir dann auch regelmäßig immer wieder Einblicke bekommen
in so die österreichische Perspektive und haben so etwas sträflicherweise so dieses Schweizer Kontext ein bisschen außen vor gelassen. Ähm wenn man da jetzt sozusagen noch überhaupt gar keinen Überblick hat, was muss man,
Wissen äh über die Schweiz. Was sind da so die,
Themen, die in den letzten Jahren vor allem gewirkt haben. Ist das mit der Situation in Deutschland irgendwie zu vergleichen oder ist das mal wieder komplett anders?
Ja, ich glaube, es sind die ungefähr dieselben Themen, die auch hier in der Schweiz ähm diskutiert werden, wo es Gesetzesvorlagen gibt,
wie das in Deutschland oder auch in Österreich ist. Wir haben aktuell Diskussionen zu Überwachungsgesetzen, sei das für die Strafverfolgungsbehörden oder für den Geheimdienst,
Es ist aber auch die Netzneutralität ein Thema oder das Urheberrecht, das äh immer mal wieder für Gesprächsstoff sorgt, auch international,
und von daher denke ich, dass.
Ja, wie gesagt, ungefähr dieselben Themen sind's, was noch zu sagen ist, dass es wahrscheinlich das Thema Netzpolitik noch,
weniger stark in der offiziellen Politik angekommen ist, als es das zum Beispiel in Deutschland ist. Es gibt wohl,
ähm ein paar wenige Politiker, die die sich in dieser Ecke auskennen und die sich auch stark machen,
aber die allermeisten äh Politiker auf auf äh Bundesebene,
die da gibt's wenig Verständnis für für diese Themen.
Fehlt wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen dieser Zensursular-Moment, ne.
Ja, das das kann durchaus sein, wobei jetzt gerade mit äh äh totale Revision des Bundesgesetzes betreffend, die wir warten, das Post- und Fernmeldeverkehrs eigentlich schon,
schon auch sehr viel auf uns zukommt, dass für mehr Aufregung sorgen müsste.
Und das kommt wohl jetzt so langsam, aber die Empörung ist nicht so groß, wie sie eigentlich sein müsste.
Wie ich das verstehe, liegt das auch ein bisschen daran, dass die Schweiz ja allgemein viel kleiner ist als
Der deutschsprachige Raum äh und die Bundesrepublik und dann gibt's da ja auch nochmal die sprachliche Dreiteilung äh und im Endeffekt
bleiben absolut viel weniger Leute übrig, die sich dann tatsächlich um einen solchen Themenbereich kümmern können. Also das sind jetzt du kennst wahrscheinlich den Großteil der Leute, die sich mit den Themenfeldern der Netzpolitik in der Schweiz beschäftigen in Deutschland, ist das schon wieder ist das schon gar nicht mehr so einfach, da wirklich Hinz und Kunz zu kennen, oder?
Ja, also es ist schon so, wie du, wie du das einschätzt. Ähm, es ist natürlich genau die Sache, dass wir ähm einerseits kleiner sind und dann nochmals sprachlich in verschiedenen Regionen aufgeteilt sind,
und das macht das Ganze schon ziemlich übersichtlich ähm und,
Ist aber ist aber ähnlich und,
da kann man sich auch nicht immer mit allem in diesem Detail gerade beschäftigen, wie man das eigentlich,
müsste. Also wir suchen auch innerhalb von der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz,
möglichst breit die Themen zu bearbeiten oder zu verfolgen, aber das gelingt uns nicht überall im selben Maße. Aber es ist auch natürlich so, dass dass wir.
Auch noch verschiedene andere Gruppierungen und Organisationen gibt, die sich natürlich Teilebereiche dann auch
verstärkt anschauen, wie es zum Beispiel eine digitale Alment ist,
sich sehr stark mit beschäftigt, die auch die äh Kreativ-Commons äh für die Schweiz adaptiert hat.
Und natürlich auch andere Gruppierungen, die sich, die sich sehr stark machen, auch der Chaos, Computerclub, Schweiz und Zürich sind ähm,
ziemlich stark und wir arbeiten einige Dinge.
Was ist denn so jetzt die die rechtliche Situation bei diesen ganzen Klassikern? Also ähm Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt's eine äh ist es überhaupt so vergleichbar.
Ich würde nochmal kurz einschieben, die Schweiz ist uns ziemlich nah, aber die ist ja eher neutral äh und nicht,
in der EU. Ich habe im Vorgespräch so ein bisschen flapsig gesagt, aber ihr macht trotzdem jeden Scheiß nach, äh den wir in der EU haben und damit kämpfen müssen,
ist das so? Sind eure äh viele der netzpolitisch relevanten, politischen Themen tatsächlich angelehnt an die Debatten, die es in der EU und auch in der Bundesrepublik gibt.
Ja, ist, teils, teils. Ähm, gerade was jetzt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung betrifft, ähm, ist es so, dass wir die schon seit über zehn Jahren kennen. Und in der abgewandelten Form sogar schon vorher.
Die wurde über die Zeit jetzt immer mehr ausgeweitet und ja, ich denke, da sind wir, wenn man das,
so sehen will, ziemlich weit vorne. Also da ist nicht so, dass wir das irgendwie abgucken.
Gesetzesvorlagen. Bei anderen Dingen ist es andersrum. Also Sachen wie Leistungsschutzrecht,
Das sind auch Dinge, die jetzt bei uns so in die Diskussion kommen.
Ach nee, das macht jetzt.
Dass es dass es angelehnt ist an an Ideen von von Deutschland oder von anderen Ländern.
Was ist denn der Status der Vorratsdatensprechung?
Ja, wir haben sie mit ganz offiziell seit es dieses Bundesgesetz betreffen die Überwachung des Post- und Fernmeldeverkehrs,
das nennt sich abgekürzt Büpf,
haben wir sechs Monate vor Ortspeicherung, die ist in der ausgestalten sehr stark vergleichbar mit der Variante, wie es sie in Deutschland gegeben hat und wie es auch der europäische Richtlinie,
vorgesehen hab.
Und die soll nun im Rahmen der totalen Revision, die aktuell ähm in den Parlamenten diskutiert wird, verdoppelt werden. Da findet eigentlich keine Diskussion statt.
Sie nun verhältnismäßig ist, ob sie für die Strafverfolgung eine Auswirkung zeigt.
Sondern da wird mehr oder weniger den Wünschen der Strafverfolgungsbehörden gefolgt und,
vorgesehen.
Verdopplung von was?
Sechs auf zwölf Monaten.
Warum hat die Schweiz überhaupt eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wenn du vorhin schon gesagt hast, äh in der EU gab's ja die Richtlinie erst seit zwotausendsechs, jetzt hatten eins nur Staaten wie Irland und Polen schon vorher eine und die Richtlinie sollte das theoretisch nur harmonisieren. Aber warum hat der die Schweizer
über zehn Jahren eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Tja, ganz gute Frage. Ähm die gibt's eigentlich schon länger,
sie war schon im Fernmeldegesetz verankert vor vor langer Zeit. Da ging es aber um,
Pflicht, die Rechnungsdaten aufzubewahren und für die Strafverfolgungsbehörden zur Verfügung zu stellen,
im Rahmen von von äh von Strafverfahren.
Einschließlich einschließlich der Einzelverbindung oder.
Schließlich der Einzelverbindungen, ja.
Okay. Also nicht nur die Rechnung, sondern auch quasi der Einzelverbindungsnach, weil.
Genau, also das war das, das ist der eigentliche Grundlage für die, für die Rechnung und,
die wurden auch natürlich in kurzen Zeitraum aufbewahrt, um Reklamationen nachkommen zu können, also Reklamation der Kunden und Kundinnen.
Und das war dann eine Verpflichtung für die die Telefonie und Vieter zu dieser Zeit,
diese Daten aufzubewahren und gegebenenfalls dann zur Verfügung zu stellen. Und das wurde dann,
übernommen ins neue wenn das in dieses Bundesgesetz und dann gleichzeitig auch auf den Internetbereich,
ausgedehnt.
Das heißt im Internet, nicht nur die Zuordnung, wer wann welche IP-Adresse hat, sondern sind da auch so Sachen wie von jeder E-Mail und von jeder Voice of IP Verbindung, wie das die U-Rischlinge vorgeschlagen hat drin.
Ist da drin, ja? Also es hat die IP-Zuordnungen sind da drin und die äh E-Mail äh Ranzdaten, also was im ähm verwendet wird an andres Angaben.
Und auch natürlich die und das soll jetzt aber mit,
Revision stark ausgeweitet werden. Aktuell sind eigentlich die Access-Provider verpflichtet, diese Daten zu speichern und neu sollen auch reine Hosting anbieter dazukommen,
und es soll auch jetzt ganz generell vom Geltungsbereich, nicht nur, was die Forstdatenspeichern betrifft, sondern auch die aktive Überwachung dieser Geltungsbereich des Gesetzes auf,
Organisationen wie oder Bibliotheken oder Hotels ausgedehnt werden und es ist sogar eine Mitwirkungspflicht bis zu privat Personen vorgesehen. Also die müssen nicht selber überwachen,
die müssen ähm Zugang gewähren. Ähm alle Informationen äh mitteilen, die sie haben und die Überwachung dulden.
Einschließlich Passwörter rausrücken.
Das ist so nicht genau definiert, das heißt im Gesetzestext sinngemäß Zugang zu den Anlagen gewähren. Irgendwo in in diesem, in diesem Wort laut,
und das das lässt sich jetzt nicht genau äh erreren, was was da eigentlich gemeint ist. Das steht auch nicht in den erläuternden Texten zum Gesetz,
dass schlussendlich bedeutet, ob man das Hochpasswort ähm.
Zu den Anlagen, also zu den eigenen Geräten sozusagen.
Das ursprünglich,
war's eigentlich so gemeint oder in den in den Elternversionen des Gesetzes, dass man physisch Zugang gewähren muss?
Aber wenn man, wenn man's eng auslegt, könnte man wahrscheinlich auch hineininterpretieren, dass es wirklich den,
das Login an sich sein könnte.
Und das ist jetzt geltendes Gesetz. Wir reden jetzt nicht über die Novelle.
Nein, das das kommt. Das ist.
Soll jetzt kommen. Okay gut, das heißt, das ist äh jetzt quasi genau die Verschärfung, die in der Debatte steht.
Ja, genau.
Gibt's eine, also ich meine, findet eine Debatte statt.
Die Debatte findet so halb statt. Es wurde,
die die Gesetzesvorlage ist zuerst in der kleinen Kammer diskutiert worden,
ist sie mehr oder weniger durchgewunken worden. Es gab wohl eine kritische Stimme, das war
hauptsächlich eine Parlamentarierin, die sich kritisch geäußert hat und kritische Fragen gestellt hat. Sie war aber leider in der Debatte nicht ganz so sattelfest, als dass sie hätte, der zuständigen Bundesrätin
Das ist die, die äh Person aus der Wechselkutive, die diese Gesetzesvorlage äh ausgearbeitet hat, als dass sie hätte parieren können.
Und jetzt kommt's dann in den Nationalrat, das ist die große
Parlamentskammer und da ist mit etwas mehr Widerstand zu rechnen, da wird's wahrscheinlich 'ne etwas breitere Diskussion geben, es ist aber davon auszugehen, dass auch hier das Gesetz,
mehr oder weniger unverändert durchgewunken wird.
Kannst du uns nochmal ganz kurz an die krassen Terroranschläge in der Schweiz der letzten Jahre erinnern, mit denen das sicherlich begründet wird?
Ich versuche mich gerade zu erinnern, aber ich habe da eine eine Lücke, eine Gedächtnis.
So geht's mir nämlich leider.
Aber ich bin mir sicher, es war total äh dramatisch und äh alle.
Ja, es ist es ist.
Schildern rum, dass das nie wieder passieren darf.
Nee, was ist die Begründung?
Die Begründung ist natürlich organisierter Kriminalität, Terrorismus, ja was man so was man so kennt, das ist dasselbe.
Und wenn man sich die Statistiken anguckt, also da gibt es welche für welche Straftaten das die, dass das angeordnete Überwachung gibt und Zugriff auf die und das ist sehr oft in das Drogendelikte.
Wo die Kategorie, die am meisten verfolgt wird.
Ähnlich wie in Deutschland.
Ja, also da da stehen die, ja, da gehen dann Terrorjugendpraxis doch ziemlich stark auseinander,
Es ist jetzt auch nicht nur so, dass der der persönliche Geltungsbereich ausgedehnt wird, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausgedehnt werden soll, sondern es kommt auch eine rechtliche Grundlage für den äh Bundestrojaner,
dazu kommen, es soll die Möglichkeit geben, dass die Polizeibehörden im einsetzen dürfen, das machen sie wohl schon heute, aber dann gibt's eine äh Gesetzesgrundlage, die auch wirklich äh,
passt. Und es sollen auch sonst neue Vorschriften für Provider gelten,
dass Qualitätskontrollen durchgeführt werden können, dass,
empfindliche Bußgelder ausgesprochen werden können, wenn die Verwalter,
Anordnungen nicht nachkommen. Also man sieht da schon so die die Handschrift der Strafverfolgungsbehörden, die 'ne gut funktionierende Überwachungsmaschine haben möchten, auf die sie zurückgreifen können.
Jetzt ist ja die Schweiz immer so bekannt oder zumindest steht's in der Diskussion für ihr großartige demokratische Systematik und der Möglichkeit gegen alles Mögliche einen Widerstand zu organisieren.
Das habt ihr ja im Prinzip vor einem Jahr, glaube ich, schon gestartet, ne?
Ja, vor einem Jahr ist das das Gesetz, so wie es jetzt äh diskutiert wird, dem Parlament vorgestellt worden.
Wer legt das vor?
Das ist der Bundesrat, das ist die Exekutive. Vorher im im im in den Monaten und Jahren davor, da gab es,
Anhörungen, Diskussionen oder
da konnte man Stellung nehmen zu zu diesem, zu dieser neuen Regulierung, aber dann vor einem Jahr wurde die aktuelle Version, wie sie den Parlament,
vorgelegt wird veröffentlicht. Und da ging dann eigentlich jetzt der aktuelle, der aktuelle Widerstand los,
wo wir uns angeklinkt haben und Stellung bezogen haben, also wir von der von der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz aus und zum Beispiel die Piraten eine eine Petition gestartet haben,
Eine Online-Petition, um Stimmen zu sammeln, die sich gegen die Vorlage wenden. Da sind in der Zwischenzeit etwa zehntausend.
Zusammengekommen, die das unterstützen, das ist nicht allzu viel, könnte mehr sein, aber ist auch kein schlechtes Zeichen. Wenn man jetzt gerade die Größe der Schweiz vergleicht mit zum Beispiel Deutschland.
Ja und ähm ist äh die äh diese Petition läuft noch.
Die Tradition läuft, die hat ärgerlich in dem Sinn kein, kein Ende. Da kann man sich nach wie vor,
die kann man abrufen auf Punkt CH.
Mhm.
Kann man sich noch beteiligen. Sie wurde mal eingereicht als die Debatte im in der Kommission in der vorbehabenden Kommission des Ständerrats,
diskutiert wurde als Zeichen, aber in dem Sinn gibt's da nicht ein offizielles Ende, wo man sagt, so und jetzt wird das irgendwie überreicht, sondern das ist etwas, was die ganze.
Die ganze Kampagne, wenn man so will, gegen dieses Gesetz begleitet.
Das ist aber jetzt auch diese von Sascha Lobo kritisierte Click die wissen, das ist halt eine Online-Petition, dazu steht noch Piratenpartei drauf, die hat jetzt keine Mitwirkungskraft. Ich glaube, was Tim vorhin angesprochen hat, mit der
Demokratie in der Schweiz ist ja die Möglichkeit unter anderem von Volksentscheiden. Nun ist das nicht so einfach mal gemacht,
Aber habt ihr darüber schon mal nachgedacht.
Ist angedacht, das ist jetzt noch nicht so aktuell, weil die Gesetzesvorlage ja noch nicht,
in der zweiten Kammer zur Diskussion äh gekommen ist. Das ist aber so, dass ähm bereits Diskussionen stattfinden, um ein mögliches Referendum,
zu stemmen. Ein Referendum heißt, dass man innerhalb von hundert Tagen,
nach der Verabschiedung eines Gesetzes. Fünfzigtausend beklabigte Unterschriften auf Papier,
einreichen muss, damit das zu einer Volksabstimmung kommt.
Nach Einreichung eines Gesetzes, also gegen.
Nach Verabschiedung. Also in dem Moment, wo der zweite Rat, also der Nationalrat in diesem Fall.
Der Gesetzesänderung zustimmt, dann braucht es noch ein paar Tage bis das offiziell veröffentlicht ist und ab diesem Zeitpunkt bleiben hundert Tage um die fünfzigtausend Unterschriften zusammen.
Um sich dann explizit gegen einen im Prinzip ab jetzt schon gültiges Gesetz zu wenden und das wiederum zu Fall zu bringen.
Genau. Also es ist ja dann noch nicht wirklich gültig. Da hat es auch Übergangsfrist und bis das dann wirklich in Kraft ist und für die paar Weide gilt, auf wirklich eine Auswirkung hat. Und während dieser Zeit, also hundert Tage ab.
Ähm Verabschiedung des Gesetz.
Hat man die Möglichkeit. Und da finden jetzt ein Zeitfenster statt, demnächst. Das wurde von äh Leuten aus der SVP, das ist stark rechts,
im politischen Spektrum wurde das,
ähm angegangen. Auch da wurde das organisiert. Es ist allerdings so, dass es über das ganze Polit-Spektrum Leute gibt, die das unterstützen. Also da braucht das von den Grünen hat,
ähm das schon angetönt, dass er das unterstützen wird, aber auch eine Person aus der FDP, darüber die Noser,
wird da wahrscheinlich auch mitziehen. Also das schein.
Nicht, dass ich dich da jetzt falsch verstanden habe. Du meintest, die SVP hat das angegangen, also die ist jetzt dafür oder dagegen? Wirklich.
Sie ist dagegen. Also sie sie würde, dass sie sie organisiert ähm eine Gruppe, die das Referendum organisieren wird.
Wer ist denn dafür im Parlament?
Im Parlament sind so ziemlich alle dafür.
Und es gibt einfach in jeder Part oder in den meisten Parteien gibt es einzelne Personen, die das ablehnen. Und auf denen baut dann eigentlich die das Referendumskomitee auf.
Aber so ein Referendum besteht ja aus zwei Hürden. Das eine ist der logistische Aufwand, fünfzigtausend beglaubigte Unterschriften auf Papier innerhalb von hundert Tagen zu sammeln.
Und dann der.
Zweite ist, da muss man ja auch die Abstimmung inhaltlich noch gewinnen,
ist ja nicht so, dass nur, weil man eine Abstimmung der Bevölkerung zur Wahl stellt, das dann automatisch heißt, dass man die auch gewinnt. Wir haben schon so manche skurrile Ergebnis aus der Schweiz gesehen, NOFENZ.
Das ist absolut richtig. Ich gehe auch mal davon aus, dass man die fünfzigtausend Unterschriften zusammenkickt, insbesondere, wenn auch Pro Weide dahinter stecken, die auch etwas Geld in die Hand nehmen. Da gibt es auch Absichtserklärungen.
Wird hinkommen, ich gehe aber mal davon aus, dass die Abstimmung nicht gewonnen werden kann.
Konstellation vor ein paar Jahren gab, als es um die Einführung des biometrischen Passes ging, der auch,
oder die Gesetzesvorlage wurde auch in den Parlamenten mehr oder weniger diskussionslos durchgewunken. Es gab eine kleine Organisation, die das
Referendum organisiert hat. Es gab dann auch eigentlich die Jungparteien, die ihr Mütter etwas vor sich hergetrieben haben und schlussendlich haben.
Ungefähr fünftausend Stimmen gefällt in der in der Endabstimmung. Also es es könnte es es gibt Überraschungen,
aber ja, es, es wäre eine Sensation, wenn man's noch kippen könnte.
Das erinnert mich auch ein bisschen an die Situation in Deutschland. Wir hatten beim AK Vorrat öfters mal Umfragen, wie die Bevölkerung denn zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung steht,
und das war immer sehr, sehr knapp,
zweiundfünfzig Prozent für Jahr und mal zweiundfünfzig Prozent für nein, je nach Umfrageinstitut äh repräsentativen Sample und großpolitischer äh Wetterlage.
Aber wenn es hart auf hart zu einer Abstimmung kommt, dann
passiert ja da vorher auch noch ein Wahlkampf, wo jede Menge Mittel reinfließen, um Leute ja auch noch zu beeinflussen. Es werden jetzt weder in Deutschland, noch auf EU-Bunde, noch in der Schweiz sicher, dass man das da sofort mit dem Rückhalt der kompletten Bevölkerung äh ein deutliches Nein erreichen könnte.
Ja, das sehe ich ja auch so.
Also, das macht ihr zwar mit und vielleicht gibt's da eine Chance, aber ihr macht dann hoffentlich auch noch andere Aktivitäten, um das zu Fall zu bringen, oder?
Ja, wir versuchen auch äh mit verschiedenen Politikern zu sprechen und das für das Thema zu sensibilisieren. Wir haben ja auch vor paar Wochen die,
Visualisierung der Vorratsdaten mit den Daten von, der ja Nationalrat ist gemacht um das,
Thema auch in die in die Medien zu zu bringen.
Ja, führ das ruhig nochmal aus. Was was habt ihr denn da genau gemacht?
Ja, wir haben ähm die Vorratsdaten sechs Monate, also genau die Periode, die die paar weiter aufbewahren müssen aktuell, die Daten von einem Pauvider oder von seinem erhalten.
Vom Mobilfunkanbieter und E-Mail-Prowder, oder?
Das ist vom Mobilfunkanbieter. Von ihm haben wir die,
erhalten und alle Kommunikations, also die die kommen die Randdaten aus der aus der Kommunikation. Also wann hat der,
Wehen angerufen, wie lange hat das Gespräch gedauert, über welchen Mobilfunkmast hat das, hat das stattgefunden,
Angaben über der Mobilfunkmast, wo wo steht der, in welcher Richtung zeigt er,
um dann entsprechend seine seine Positionsdaten zu zu visualisieren übern über den Zeitraum von.
Das, was Maltes, das was Malte Spitz in Deutschland schon mal gemacht hat.
Das ist eine ziemlich ähnliche Aktion. Äh ziemlich ähnliche Visualisierung auch, wie die von Malte Spitz. Was wir noch dazu gemacht haben, ist aus den E-Mail Daten Beziehungsnetz.
Dargestellt. Also wer steht mit wem, wie häufig im Kontakt.
Und ähm der Michael, der hat dir das hauptsächlich gemacht von von Open Day the City, das sind die selben Leute, die ja auch die Visualisierung vermalte Spitz gemacht haben, haben auch noch,
über deinen Tagesverlauf äh aufgezeigt, wo er sich dann.
Am meisten aufhält oder wo er sich zu welcher Stunde, in welchem Tag aufhält aufhält, umso ungefähr zu sehen, wie sein Tagesablauf,
ist. Das war auch noch eine sehr spannende äh Sache.
Dass Beziehungsnetzwerk ist ziemlich cool, äh natürlich auch die Visualisierung mit den Geodaten und der Kommunikation, wann er mit wem wie lange kommuniziert
werden wir beides verlinken, das Beziehungsnetzwerk ist so 'ne interaktive Netzwerkgrafik mit Verbindungen zwischen Punkten quasi, mit seinen, mit den Kontakt
in seiner E-Mail in Box. Je größer die Punkte, desto mehr E-Mails hatte er, mit denen kommuniziert und da kann man richtig gut sehen, Cluster von seiner Fraktion, seiner Partei,
größte Punkt ist äh seine Frau, die dann
wiederum mit allen äh oder mit vielen der anderen Abgeordneten und Parteifunktionären in Kontakt war und dann noch jede Menge rote Punkte, die alle Anwälte sind, die ja eigentlich nach Bundes- und EU-Rechnung mal eine besonders geschützte Kommunikations äh Verhältnis haben.
Müsste so sein, ja.
Verlinken wir nochmal. Sieht äh ziemlich cool aus, mal wieder großartige Leistungen von Michael Kreil, habe ich auch gleich in meinem Republika Talk auf der Vorratsseite verwendet und hat das ähnlich eingeschlagen wie in,
Deutschland, die Veröffentlichung zu Malte, der hat ja dann immerhin mal einen TED Talk draus gemacht.
Ja, ich habe das nicht mehr so präsent, wie das in Deutschland war dazu mal,
Bei uns war es so, es ist in allen größeren Zeitungen ist was gekommen.
Das eilig auch mit zwei Medienpartnern gemeinsam gemacht. Wir haben dann auch entsprechend natürlich darüber berichtet.
Wer waren die Medienpartner?
Das war die Schweiz am Sonntag, das ist eine der großen Sonntagszeitungen in der Schweiz und ein neues Online-Portal, das nennt sich Watson CH.
Was was äh worauf bezieht sich Watson CH.
Äh das ist Whats on.
Ach so, what's ordentlich? Äh hört ihr jetzt den anderen Watson so im Kopf, das ist ja gerade im Bereich Datamin.
Gewesen von IBM, was äh alles vorweggenommen hat.
Ja, ähm ja, Michael Krail hat mir übrigens hier auch, Lok Buch Netzpolitik achtunddreißig, es hat schon viele Gründe gegeben, ihn ein weiteres Mal einzuladen, vielleicht machen wir das auch nochmal. Ähm,
was mich noch interessiert, ich meine in Deutschland ist ja dann letzten Endes die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Kann man sagen, zunächst einmal über das Bundesverfassungsgericht, zumindest partiell zu Fall gekommen,
Jetzt äh ist mein Verständnis von der Schweiz, dass es ein entsprechendes Äquivalent so gar nicht äh gibt in der deutsch in der schweizerischen im schweizerischen Rechtssystem.
Nein, das haben wir leider nicht. Wir haben keinen Verfassungsgericht, das unmittelbar auf auf Gesetzes, auf Gesetze Einfluss nehmen könnte.
Aber es gibt auch da einen Bundesgericht, also welche.
Ja, die haben aber die haben keine Kompetenz, ähm um da einzugreifen,
nichts, desto haben wir aber dennoch Anfang diesen Jahres eine Beschwerde gegen die vor Ortsdatenspeicherung erhoben.
Bei der zuständigen Behörde. Das ist der Dienst, betreffend die Überwachung des Post- und Fernmeldeverkehrs.
Und da sollte jetzt in diesen Tagen eine Verfügung kommen.
Dass sie das natürlich nicht unterlassen können, weil es eine gesetzliche Grundlage gibt,
diese Verfügung, die werden wir dann ans Bundesverwaltungsgericht weiterziehen und von daher aus entweder ans Bundesgericht oder direkt an den europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass der Europäische Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte,
ähnlich urteilen wird, wie es das EuGH kürzlich gemacht hat.
Also da stehen die Chancen gut, dass ähm ähm die Vorratsdatenspeicherung unzulässiges Mitglied.
Angesehen wird. Politisch ist dann allerdings nochmal 'ne andere Sache
Europäische Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte, der kann nicht direkt Gesetze in der Schweiz außer Kraft setzen, aber natürlich hat dann das in der weiteren politischen Debatte ein ganz großes Gericht.
Bin ich gerade selber etwas verwirrt der Europäische Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte ist aber jetzt kein EU-Organ, ne. Hm.
Nein. Nein. Das ist die europäische Menschenrechtskonvention.
Ja. Das heißt, das hat äh für die Schweiz jetzt auch Relevanz.
Äh hinaus, weil ich meine und das Urteil des äh EUGH, was wir ja hier auch schon äh besprochen hatten, was ja jetzt im Prinzip auch so die jüngste zweite Phase der Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdiskussion in Deutschland
Zumindest vorläufig äh gekillt hat, äh hatte das in der Schweiz Auswirkung, dass es da zur Kenntnis genommen worden.
Es ist zur Kenntnis genommen worden, aber natürlich mit dem Verweis, dass das, dass sich das auf EU-Recht stützt und dass das eine Beschwerde aus Österreich und Irland war und insofern für die Schweiz keine direkte,
natürlich auch stimmt.
Oh man.
Ja, ja, das rein rechtlich ist das natürlich nachvollziehbar. Ich frage mich nur, ob das jetzt, äh sagen wir mal so, auch ich weiß nicht.
Also in der Debatte verwenden wir das natürlich. Das ist das ist ganz klar.
Ja. Aber ich meine, wie wie ist das so in der schweizerischen Gesellschaft, also äh wird alles, was das EU-Label hat, immer noch so pauschal ausgeblendet? Und das betrifft uns gar nicht. Oder äh hat das eigentlich schon Relevanz.
Das wird schon beobachtet. Also es wird vor allem auch stark beobachtet, was zum Beispiel in Deutschland geschieht. Also deutsche Politik hat,
wird durchaus stark beobachtet und hat dann entsprechende Auswirkungen. Ich weiß nicht, wie's in der französischsprachigen Schweiz ist. Vielleicht wird da eher nach Frankreich geguckt,
aber das hat schon, das hat natürlich schon Auswirkungen, also da richtet man sich schon auch danach, die die Diskussion werden dann und die Argumente werden auch übernommen und und ausgetauscht.
Ja, Frankreich.
Es ist natürlich schon so, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als Begriff, der ist, der war lange, lange nicht bekannt. Also ich würde mal, ich würde mal sagen, der ist so im im Verlauf des letzten Jahres, ist der so wirklich mal durch alle Medien durchgesickert,
vorher war das war das nicht,
Kant. Vielleicht hat man aber darüber berichtet, dass in Deutschland die Vorratsdatenspeicherung vom vom Verfassungsgericht gekippt wurde, aber man hat eigentlich nicht die Parallele gezogen und gesagt,
hey, wir haben das bei uns in in der ähnlichen Form ja auch.
Und das hat sich jetzt zum Glück in den letzten Monaten hat sich das ähm verändert.
Wann werdet ihr die Klage einrechen? Weil das könnt ihr ja eigentlich auch schon gegen das bestehende Gesetz, ne?
Das ist gegen das bestehende Gesetz. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also die die Beschwerde, die ist jetzt am Laufen.
Und sobald wir die die Verfügung haben, also es ist jetzt eigentlich noch ein Besuch auf Unterlassung und wenn wir die Verfügung haben, werden wir an die nächste Instanz, das ist das Bundesverwaltungs.
Moment, Moment, ihr ihr sagt, ihr wollt gerichtlich klären lassen, dass das nicht geht und ihr wartet jetzt ab, dass ein Gericht sagt, doch ist schon in Ordnung, weil Gesetz und dann wollt ihr dagegen klagen.
Genau, das ist dann eine Beschwerde, ja.
Wie gut seid ihr denn so personell aufgestellt? Gibt's da genug äh Mitstreiter in euren Reihen? Habt ihr genug äh juristisches Personal? Seid ihr noch auf der Suche nach äh Mithelfern.
Wir sind natürlich auf der Suche nach Leute, die die mitziehen auf Organisationen, die mitziehen. Wir sind aber auch,
eine schöne Anzahl an Personen, die sich auch juristisch auskennen. Das hat sich
äh sehr gut ergeben in den letzten Monaten und Jahren. Äh gestartet sind wir eher aus der von der technischen Seite her. Viele Informatiker, die
die sich mit
mit dem dieser netzpolitischen Dingen beschäftigt haben und jetzt sind aber doch einige äh Anwälte und Juristen dazugestoßen und dass das hilft, sehr viel, um um in diesen in diesen Themen arbeiten zu können.
Trotzdem gibt's irgendwie Orte, Treffen, Veranstaltungen, die ihr durchführt oder die andere durchführen, wo potenziell interessierte neue Mitstreiter auch äh andocken könnten.
Ja, was wir regelmäßig machen, das ist das früher, also das Herbst treffen, dass wir als Treffen, das war vor zwei Monaten,
und das Herbsttreffen, das wird dann im Oktober stattfinden. Ansonsten.
Findet das statt? In Zürich?
Findet in Weimarten statt. Das ist etwas auf dem Lande,
was es gibt, es geht ein Treffen, das mehr oder weniger regelmäßig in Zürich noch stattfindet, ist aber wieder Mittag, das nennen wir so den,
das Mittagessen für für netzpolitisch interessierte Personen,
und ansonsten sind wir eigentlich über und Mails allgemein im Kontakt.
Ja sag doch mal ein paar wo sollen denn all die Lokbuchnetzpolitik Hörerinnen die jetzt Lust haben sich in der Schweiz einzubringen, sich hinmelden? Ist das digitale Gesellschaft CH und dann durchklicken oder.
Das ist, das ist sicher die beste Adresse, da sind auch alle Organisationen, die angeschlossen sind, verlinkt. Weil man sich dann vielleicht etwas spezifischer für für ein Thema interessiert, dann lohnt es sich bestimmt auch äh da dann zu gucken.
Wo man wo man sich engagieren könnte, aber natürlich auch in die digitale Gesellschaft Schweiz, also alle, die netzpolitisch interessiert, engagiert sind,
Sie können sich sehr gerne melden auch einfach übers Kontaktformular und dann werden entsprechende Kontakte hergestellt. Was es noch gibt,
wo wir eigentlich um Leute wo Leute wichtig sind, dass sie teilnehmen würden, es ist,
in zwei Wochen heute, in zwei Wochen, ist eine Kundgebung angesagt gegen dieses Überwachungsgesetz, ähm das ist,
in Bern am Samstag, einunddreißigsten Mai, wo die
Die ähnlichen Akteure, außer praktisch aller Jungparteien, aber auch die CTC Schweiß, die digitale Gesellschaft, Schweiz et cetera zu einer zu einer großen und bunten Kundgebung auf dem Bundesplatz,
aufrufen. Also das ist auch eine gute Gelegenheit, um gegen das Überwachungsgesetz ein Zeichen zu setzen, aber natürlich auch um Leute zu treffen.
Ja, haben wir noch irgendwas ganz Wichtiges äh vergessen? Musst du noch erwähnen möchtest in dem gesamte.
Nein, ich denke nicht. Also was sich jetzt gerade das Überwachungsgesetz anbelangt, haben wir doch sehr ausführlich jetzt darüber gesprochen, ja.
Gut und das steht ja nun mal im äh Mittelpunkt
Ja, fein. Vielleicht äh buchen wir dich äh in künftigen Sendungen nochmal äh dazu, um so die Fortschritte auch nochmal zu bemessen und sicherlich werden ja auch noch andere Themen äh in der Schweiz hochkommen. Ich denke, das ist recht wichtig, dass man,
da auch den Blick drauf hält und da auch so die potentielle wie soll ich sagen Erfahrungs Weiterreichung betreibt so.
Ja klar, sehr gerne.
So zwischen Österreich, Schweiz, Deutschland, ähm bin nicht sogar ganz Europa und Brüssel. Ja,
Andre, hast du noch eine Frage? Sonst würden wir nämlich jetzt den Erik erstmal verabschieden.
Ich will mich bedanken bei Erik. Es war ja schon lange.
Möchte mich auch bedanken.
Mal das Lokbuchnetz Politik Korrespondentennetzwerk auch noch um die Schweiz zu erweitern. Dann haben wir dann äh fast alle deutschsprachigen äh Staaten in der näheren Visinity.
Genau, wir überwachen jetzt alle, überwachen jetzt alle.
Netzpolitik Ork hat er ja schon ab und zu mal einen Gastbeitrag abgeliefert.
Und wir hoffen, dass wir das auch zukünftig aufrecht erhalten können.
Ja, sehr gerne, ich möchte mich bedanken.
Okay, alles klar. Dann.
Okay, noch viel Spaß.
Tschüss. So. Wo machen wir denn weiter?
Sind wir wieder alleine. Wo machen wir denn weiter? Laut Sendeplan in der Republiker.
Aha, aha, gut, dass wir einen Plan haben. Ja, Republika, wir haben's ja schon angesprochen, die war grade mal wieder
Sollte irgendjemand da äh gerade unter seinem Stein hervorgekommen sein, äh Rupublica, äh mittlerweile eine wirklich große Veranstaltung. Ich weiß nicht, ist irgendeine offizielle Teilnehmerzahl genannt worden oder haben die alle Angst?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe vorher irgendwas von sechstausend gehört, sechs, siebentausend oder so. Ich habe mich aber auch nicht gekümmert um.
Ich schätze mal, in dem in dem in dem Bereich bewegt es sich.
Republika war auch wie so ein Stein, also das ist echt, man hat so sein klein eigenes Ding, aber da draußen passiert noch das ganz große Republika-Ding und so wirklich alles mitzubekommen, geht schlecht.
Nö, das ist natürlich unmöglich, ganz klar, aber es ähm zeigt eben auch, wie viel Vielfalt so in dieser ganzen Bewegung mit äh drin ist. Meine Republika ist halt
einerseits eine große Veranstaltung häufig und wie ich finde vollkommen zu Unrecht so als Blogger-Messe äh verschrien. Das ist sie sicherlich nicht,
wenn es natürlich ausm Blogger Umfeld heraus äh gegründet worden ist, aber eben mit so einem starken, ich würde sagen, mit so einer gesunden Mischung aus äh,
Politischen, gesellschaftspolitischen Fokus.
Zum kulturellen, netzkulturellen äh Element und natürlich auch ähm mit einer,
wie soll ich sagen, mit einer grundlegenden Offenheit auch zu diesen Business äh und Vermarktungsaspekten, ohne jetzt wirklich, dass,
Primär zu verfolgen. Wie das manchmal so wahrgenommen wird, aber finde, das hat sich so nie bestätigt und auch dieses Jahr war insbesondere auch der netzpolitische Fokus relativ stark.
Dieses Jahr war ja noch mehr. Dieses Jahr war ja dann auch die Media Convention,
eingegliedert, während man zwotausendsieben noch dieses komische Blogger versus Journalisten-Dingen hatte, äh scheint das jetzt auch ein bisschen sich beruhigt zu haben und man kann ruhig auch mal was zusammen machen,
dann gab's am.
Ist fast fast vorbei, ne?
Na, bis auf das Zeitunnel, was zum dreißig C drei noch mal ausgegraben hat, aber ich habe mich schon beschwert. Ähm,
Naja und bei Glenbold kommt das auch ab und zu in den Staaten nochmal hoch, aber dann hatten wir am Donnerstag nach dem äh auch Republika Dienstag und Mittwoch die Media Convention
der Station Berlin war, waren dann am Donnerstag, Freitag und ich glaube, auch nach Samstag äh der LINUX Tag und die,
in den selben Räumen, was zu einer lustigen Durchmischung des Publikums geführt hat, also nicht nur die Kernrepublika selbst
und die äh ja, erweitert sich
ständig von diesem ursprünglichen Bloggertreffen, sondern auch andere Veranstaltungen drum rum, was immer mal in dieser Berlin Web Week oder wie das da alles so heißt, krumm gewuselt hat, das verzahnt sich immer mehr in den letzten Jahren,
Ich finde das sehr spannend. Ein bisschen habe ich mich jetzt,
Na ja, früher war alles besser, ein bisschen zurückgesehen, dann so die ersten Republikas, wirklich mit unter tausend Leuten in der Kalkshow im Hof zu stehen und tatsächlich mit jeden auch mal kurz ein Bier trinken zu können
das geht heutzutage nicht mehr, da ist so viel los, so viel Input, zwölf Bühnen gleichzeitig. Wie, das kann man doch nicht mal mehr nachgucken. Äh ich habe,
Audios und einige Videos auf Platte liegen. Ich weiß schon, dass ich nicht dazu kommen werde, mir auch alle Interessenten, die ich gerne live gesehen hätte, dann auch wirklich nochmal anzugucken,
ist es extrem viel los, es hat sich extrem verbreitet.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist so das eine oder andere, was man auch mal nachschauen sollte. Es waren wirklich äh eine ganze Reihe von äh wirklich guten Präsentationen dabei. Ich habe
meine Nachschauliste auch noch nicht durch, aber ich habe auch so ein bisschen das Echo äh mitgenommen. Es gibt ja auch so ein paar Klassiker auf dieser Veranstaltung. Da ist ja der dreißig C drei nicht äh alleine.
Ihr auch ein Logo.
Ja, mehrere sogar.
Ja, wahrscheinlich brauchen solche Veranstaltungen so was auch. Also es gibt da, glaube ich, auch schon so eine gewisse Sehnsucht, dass man eben auch bestimmte Persönlichkeiten, die einfach bewiesen haben, dass äh auch wenn man vielleicht ihre Meinung nicht unbedingt immer teilt
dass sie zumindest in der Lage sind 'ne Debatte aufzurufen, auszulösen.
Und äh ist beim Kongress auch nicht anders, ja, also
Wie Frank Rieger oder so sind da definitiv Teil äh dieses Systems, gibt's aber auch noch ein paar andere. Sascha Lobo ist einer davon, wobei äh der Vortrag, auf den ich mich eigentlich selber immer äh am meisten freue, ähm.
Ist der von IX äh Wirres Punkt Net nach wie heißt er? Äh Felix Schwenzel, genau, der,
Also erstmal mag ich seinen seinen lockeren Stil so und er hat auch einfach,
Die Gabe, die Dinge auch einfach nochmal so ganz unaufgeregt von der anderen Seite zu beleuchten, ohne jetzt große,
Wie soll ich sagen, plakative Thesen in den Raum zu stellen, obwohl er zumindest es äh geschafft hat, schon äh mit seinem Titel
wie es nochmal genau wie ich lernte die Überwachung zu lieben so mit dieser Anspielung und
schön durch diesen ganzen Diskurs äh durchgegangen ist und diese ganze Frage, die er auch,
Bei Sascha Lobo die ganze Zeit so im Raum schwebt immer so, wir sind doch irgendwie alle dagegen, warum kommen wir denn da politisch irgendwie nicht vorwärts, nicht? Und zum Beispiel Lober hat's in seinem Talk halt äh extrem so äh mal auch so die finanzielle Situation angesprochen. Das hatte schon enormen Fokus. Das war nicht das Einzige, aber es äh stach heraus
diesen Vergleich aufgerufen mit äh
Hier der Vogelschutzbund in Bayern wirft irgendwie Millionen äh da drauf, dass man irgendwie die Vögel erforscht und äh so ein Vogel des Jahres wählt. Ähm.
Und äh die netzpolitische äh Bewegung schafft's noch nicht mal sich äh zehn feste Mitarbeiter übers Jahr zu finanzieren,
das kann man jetzt so sehen oder nicht und äh der Vortrag von Felix war halt sehr,
dass er eben auch mal sehr hinterfragt hat, nicht? Inwiefern inwiefern es nicht vielen dann eben dann doch auch,
egal ist und wie sich das alles manifestiert.
Ich habe den Vortrag von Felix nicht gesehen, liegt auf der Platte. Eins der vielen, eine der vielen Sachen.
Ja, also den den solltest du dir dann mal äh holen. Ich mag auch immer, dass er sich dann andere Vorträge so anschaut und die dann auch mal gleich mit einarbeitet. Also es ist sozusagen auch immer sehr äh kontextreich. Das äh schönes Ding.
Um den Logo kümmern ist drumrum, oder? Was hälst du denn davon?
Ich bin ja nun, ich bin ja leicht befangen, weil er immerhin aufgerufen hat und zwei Vereine, die ich jeweils mitgegründet habe, die Netzpolitik e.V.
Äh quasi all euer Geld zu spenden. Das finde ich natürlich inhaltlich super und ich war, glaube ich, auch der Erste, der geklatscht hat, als er gesagt hat, dass er seine Spiegel-Online-Kolumne seit dem fünften Juni,
Jahres jedes einzelne Jahr nicht ausschließlich der hat auch andere Themen äh mit eingebaut, aber in jedem einzelnen Beitrag war trotzdem,
wie hat der das ausgedrückt? Der Tyrannosaurus Rex, der im Raum ist mit Thema. Man kann nicht,
wie unsere Minister das Thema irgendwie ausblenden oder sagen, da drüben ist ein bunter Pudel, äh wie Sascha das so gesagt hat. Ich finde das wirklich verdienter von mir großen Respekt, dieses Thema in diesem Medium,
Auf so hohem Niveau auch noch mit seinen Analysen die ganze Zeit aufrecht zu erhalten.
Ja, das ist wahr. Äh bewundernswert und bewunders bewundernswertesten fand ich, dass ihm auch jede Woche wieder was Neues eingefallen ist
äh was man da als Aspekt überhaupt aufgreifen kann, weil nicht immer war ja die Nachrichtenlage so äh dankbar, dass man da äh äh einfach sich immer an den Ereignissen immer wieder darauf beziehen konnte, sondern teilweise ich würde nicht sagen, es war an den Haaren herbeigezogen, sondern er musste einfach äh da auch ähm,
Theoretische, konzeptionelle Brücken bauen und irgendwie auch aus anderen Geschehnissen ähm diesen Gesamtbereich wieder mit einfließen lassen. Das ist ihm wohl ganz gut gelungen. Ich habe jetzt auch nicht wirklich jede einzelne Kolumne gelesen.
Andererseits bin ich mir auch nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt auch immer so gut ist, wenn man quasi auch äh so wahrgenommen wird. Äh dass man ja immer dasselbe erzählt,
das dann sozusagen auch schon keine Überraschung mehr hat, weil sozusagen eigentlich schon weiß, worum sich die nächste Kolumne dreht. Ähm und trotzdem, trotzdem solche Leistungen verbracht werden, ähm ist es aber auch einfach so, dass,
die Debatte halt so ein bisschen feststeckt, dass einfach die Leute,
einfach nicht wiederhallen wollen in dem Maße äh auf dieses Thema,
Das ist wirklich immer noch eine sehr kleine Szene ist, die sich da engagiert darum bemüht und die da dieses Bedrohungspotential sieht, aber dass sich einfach dieses Bedrohungspotential,
Das ist auch zu allgemein ist, dass es zu wenig greifbar ist, dass dieses äh Anrufen des Verlustes der Freiheit als solcher einfach,
zu wenig fassbar ist,
dass einfach jeder Einbrecher mit Maske, äh wie jetzt schön wieder im Europawahl äh Kampf überall plakatiert wird, zumindest äh außerhalb,
Sehr schön, wenn man aus Berlin rausfährt und da mal so guckt, wie so im Vorort so von der CDU plakatiert wird, dann sind's halt einfach solche Sachen, ja, irgendwie so Einbrecher mit Brecheisen und schwarzer Maske, so, damit wir sicher leben können, so.
Gibt's doch heute auch schon mit schwarzer Maske, Brecheisen und Laptop in der Hand.
Ja ja. Das ist die digitale Variante, aber,
Worauf ich hinaus will, ist, dass einfach dieser dieser politische Diskurs sich ja äh zu unserem fortsetzenden äh Bedauern, aber es ist halt auch äh ohne Überraschung dabei. Äh eben immer gerne so auf,
Einfach zu erzählen, eine Geschichte niederschlägt und es wurde nun auch viel beklagt, dass das äh Narrativ nicht äh gefunden wird. Dann gab's dann auch noch einen anderen Vortrag von ähm Friedemann.
Karik, der hat das so unter diesem Schlagwort Überwachung macht impotent. Auch nochmal so auf diese Narrativ Sache äh heruntergebracht.
Nur die Vorschläge überzeugen dann halt auch irgendwie nicht. Es ist einfach der Versuch der Zuspitzung einer Debatte, die einfach keinen so richtig erreichen will. Und man merkte äh also
Überwachung bei Impotent. Ich hatte auch das Gefühl so diese Überwachungsdebatte macht auch irgendwie diese ganze äh Szene irgendwie impotent, aber im im eigentlichen Wortsinn, dass man einfach so eine gewisse Ohnmächtigkeit auch äh spürt.
Womit ich auch gar nicht sagen will, dass das jetzt alles vergeblich und vergebens war. Es ist schon äh auch bemerkenswert, dass,
Diskussion überhaupt noch geführt wird? Also sie ist halt irgendwie auch noch da. Ist nicht komplett gestorben. Es ist nicht
weg. Es gibt am laufenden Meter immer wieder noch Snowden und Posts, Snowden und ähnliche äh Sachen. Vieles Neues über das äh berichtet wird, wird auch immer wieder dieser Bezug gesucht und so diese dieser Zeitenwende Aspekte, dieses,
wie wir ja jetzt wissen, sind die Dinge ja anders, also die Grundlagen haben sich schon,
geändert. Trotzdem war immer noch viel Gewedel und heiße Luft und man muss sich natürlich auch fragen. Ja, warum finanziert sich denn die Szene keine,
äh schlagkräftige Mannschaft, die bedrohtem Cape irgendwie dem.
Bösen Feldherren sich entgegenstellt.
Sagt es mir, ich sitze da am receiving End.
Ja, wir haben ja auf Netzpolitik auch so den Lobbyeffekt in den Spenden kurz mal verblockt. Ich glaube, der äh zieht das auch
bald nach, das ist jetzt natürlich ein Peak und wir werden sehen, ob das mal so das, wie er das auch genannt hat, einmalige Gewissen beruhigen ist oder ob sich das tatsächlich in Fördermitgliedschaften oder Daueraufträgen niederschlägt, was dann eben tatsächlich substanzielle
langfristige Arbeit ermöglicht. Wie zur Rettung der, wie hieß dieser lustige Vogel? Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Ähm ich hab's auch vergessen.
Wie zur Rettung des bayerischen Vogels, der bedroht ist.
Hat aber ja Pole des Jahres. Hatte auf jeden Fall einen schönen, langen Schnabel gehabt, zahl ganz lustig aus, der Vogel. Ja, was fällt dir noch ein? Zur Republika.
Es war viel, es war, ich habe das vorhin schon mal angedeut.
Noch Vorträge, hast du denn überhaupt irgendwelche gesehen?
Ja, na klar, habe.
Jenseits dessen, die dennoch in äh Erinnerung geblieben sind.
Ich habe mir natürlich Jilan, Si York und Jacob Apple Baum angeguckt, let's talk about Sex Baby, let's rock about PGP, äh die,
die Frage, ja aber nur die ein Prozent der Nerds verschlüsseln und das ist ja alles gar nicht zugänglich und warum sollten wir überhaupt verschlüsseln versuchen zu beantworten mit dem,
aber nicht komplett äh unzutreffenden Vergleich von sechs Praktiken in den vor allen achtziger Jahren,
heutzutage ja,
bin gerade hierher gefahren mit der Straßenbahn, da sind ich nutze Kondome, Plakate, immer noch draußen. Sowas fehlt für die digitale Welt,
und die Internet
und so, dann ist die NSA da. Äh man sollte auch im Internet bissel Surfpraktiken oder wie auch immer das genannt wird, anwenden. Man gefährdet nämlich nicht nur sich selbst, sondern auch äh die Kommunikationspartner.
Den fand ich ganz gut. Gesehen habe ich noch Eric King von Pradacy International aus UK äh zur Geschichte der Five Eyes,
eine halbe Stunde lang vorgetragen hat, wo die herkommen, fand ich auch sehr spannend. Du merkst, ich bleibe in dem Überwachungsthema.
Ja, ja, ne, ist ja gut, Fokus zu haben.
Morgen ich hoffe das hab ich jetzt richtig ausgesprochen diese Ex-Google-Mitarbeiter der in seiner internationale Staatstrojaner auf der ganzen Welt auseinander nimmt von Fin Fischer zu Hacking Team.
Der in seinem Vortrag mal song gedropt hat, dass er jetzt beweisen kann, dass fünf Fische auch in Ägypten eingesetzt wurde während der Revolution.
Dann hatte ich einen eigenen Vortrag gehalten über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wir hatten zusammen mit Anaby Sali von auch Vernetzpolitik Ork. Wir hatten drauf stehen Vorratsdatenspeicherung für Einsteiger und Fortgeschrittene,
Zum Glück habe ich ganz am Anfang mal gefragt, wer fühlt sich denn als fortgeschritten? Hm, da gingen wenige Hände hoch äh und bei der Antwort zu Einsteigern war tatsächlich mindestens der halbe Saal.
Der sich gemeldet hat, was mich sehr überrascht hat, aber auch sehr gefreut hat.
Meinst du jetzt? Also Einsteiger ähm.
Wer fühlt sich als Thema Einsteiger in Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung? Wer weiß noch nicht, was komplett gespeichert wird, was das bedeutet äh und was die Gesetzesgebungsprozesse dahinter sind.
Das war für mich überraschend, dass so wenige Leute da schon so fest sind wie wir, die wir langsam betriebsblind sind,
seit zwotausendfünf bearbeiten wir dieses Thema, seitdem die äh EU da erste Vorschläge gemacht haben, dass es jetzt neun Jahre her, an jeden neuen Gesetzentwurf dran und natürlich werden wir da mit der Zeit ein bisschen betriebsblind und
erklären nicht jedes Mal nochmal, was das jetzt eigentlich von Grund auf bedeutet, das haben wir dann dort
In einem Schnelldurchlauf nochmal, welche Daten werden da eigentlich gespeichert? Die Visualisierung von zum äh die da sehr helfen
Auswirkungen das hat, was politischen Prozesse auf EU und Bundesebene sind, erläutern haben ja den
Zahl drei oder so war das Übervollgemacht und auch gutes Feedback bekommen. Das hat mich überrascht, aber sehr gefreut.
Ähm zusammen mit einer hast du den Vortrag gehalten, ne? Mhm.
Auch von Netzpolitik org. Und dann habe ich die Republikaner natürlich zu dem genutzt, weswegen sie eigentlich da ist, im Hof stehen und Bier trinken.
Ja, genau. Ja, das äh funktioniert da immer wieder erstaunlich gut. Wetter war leider nicht ganz so gut. Äh Republika hatte so über die letzten Jahren, aber erstaunlichen Dreckrekord mit äh den Frühlingsanfang, aber auch wirklich genau treffen.
Einmal nicht in einen in der Kalkscheune, aber an.
Hat's da geregnet und ansonsten war immer brilliantes Wetter, irgendwie genau in der Woche ging's los. Das äh trotz der Verschiebung nach hinten will das jetzt irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Es hat aber auch nicht so lang und so sehr geregnet. Es kam auch mal die Sonne raus. War in Ordnung.
Ja, ja, also es war nicht wirklich komplett dramatisch, aber es fehlte so ein bisschen so dieses wonigliche Strandgefühl ähm.
Wie kamst du denn raus aus deiner Höhle Sendezentrum?
Ach das da hab ich jetzt nicht unbedingt die ganze Zeit verbracht, das hat sich vor allem sehr schön selbst organisiert, weil wir da einfach so 'ne Community an Start bekommen haben.
Die Podcast-Community, die da.
Community, genau, die da äh sozusagen das Sendezentrum gemacht hat, also das ist ja quasi so unsere Idee, auf so einer durch
private Medienproduktion geborene Veranstaltung dann auch mal mit dem Aspekt von privater Medienproduktion zu konfrontieren beziehungsweise einfach die Möglichkeit zu geben da dem auch beizuwohnen oder es doch zumindest dort aktiv zu betreiben.
Letzteres war äh im letzten Jahr noch eine Idee, das hat jetzt sehr gut funktioniert, also es waren da wirklich alle Slots belegt und äh am laufenden Meter wurden da Sendungen aufgenommen
Jetzt sind wir da.
Mehr bekommen.
Hast gar keinen mehr bekommen, genau, also es war dann einfach früh weg, was uns auch so ein bisschen, glaube ich, auf dem Pfad bringt, dass wir dann eben, sollte sich das wiederholen können, wo ich recht zuversichtlich bin
Dass du dann eben auch noch ein bisschen stärker da äh kuratieren und einfach zusehen, dass das Programm, was da dann gefahren wird, auch insgesamt für die Republika vielleicht interessant,
Ja, ist, weil am.
Besucherzuspruch hat es noch etwas gemangelt. Das ist vor allem aber dieser neuen Location geschuldet gewesen, die wir von der wir zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht so richtig wussten, wie wir für die am besten werben,
Das hat man so probiert
ist äh man darf sich natürlich da auch keine Illusionen machen, so eine Konferenz hält viele Leute immer enorm auf Trab und wie du schon sagtest, man hetzt im Prinzip von Vortrag zu Vortrag und ist dann immer froh, wenn man dann auf dem Hof äh gucken kann, wer ist denn sonst noch so da?
Sich irgendwie nochmal so 'ne Stunde irgendwo reinzusetzen und 'n Podcast zu verfolgen,
Ist schwierig, aber äh in dem Moment, wo wir früher und besser planen und besser kuratieren, äh werden wir dann ja auch äh Teil des Programms, was wir so nur für die Sondersendung einmal am Tag waren
und äh da sehe ich äh noch Entwicklungspotential. Also so oder so war das aber eine nette Sache und wir müssen natürlich die Akustik einfach ein bisschen besser in den Griff kriegen.
Da wirst du ja aber nie zufrieden.
Ja gut, das war natürlich jetzt schon etwas sakral da, nicht? Also es äh äh wir haben's zumindest so weit gedämmt bekommen, dass es überhaupt zu ertragen war. Also meine Befürchtung, am Anfang war schon so, dass wir's jetzt noch nicht mal hinbekommen, dass man überhaupt was versteht
ging schon ganz gut, aber es war schon noch eine ganze Menge dabei, aber ich denke, dass äh das lässt sich alles realisieren. Vielleicht äh auch nochmal ein äh Vortrags
Tipp von mir, der sitzt so nur so am Rande im Kontext mit den anderen Sachen steht. Ach so, hast du den Vortrag von Erich Möchel eigentlich.
Ja, ja, Erich war auch großartig.
Genau, die sollen wir vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen, was war da so seine Kernaussage?
Erich hat auch nochmal.
Also Erich, möchten wir uns nochmal kurz erwähnen, äh österreichischer Journalist äh seit äh Ewigkeiten im ORF und vor allem bekannt darüber, dass er die Future Zone, das Blog äh dort lange gemacht hat, bis es dann mal so aus.
Und noch viel länger als ORF von Future Zone Telepolis. Genau. Damals, also wirklich Internet.
Genau, also äh sozusagen ein echtes äh Bericht äh Erstattungsurgestein, der immer schon viel gebracht hat und auch jetzt nicht müde wird, das zu machen, obwohl ihm die Future Zone ja unterm Arsch weggezogen wurde, kann man sagen.
In den Neunzigern schon zu Eschelon und äh internationalen Überwachungsstandards und Überwachungsgremien berichtet hat, wo das wirklich noch extrem alud Thema war,
heutzutage gar nicht mehr so ist, äh aber da trotzdem ein immensen Wissensschatz hat und sich in Prozesse einarbeiten,
und das auch tut, in der das Wenige andere Journalisten, wenn überhaupt im deutschsprachigen Raum machen. Und er hat,
nochmal berichtet, wie es so eben Standardisierungsgremien gibt, wie teilweise im Etsy, was irgendwie european, Telekomunikation Standards.
Institut,
wo eben unter anderem technische Spezifikationen auch für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, aber für viele andere,
äh also Kapazitäten, die in Kommunikationsnetzen, wie Telefonnetz, Mobil, Funknetz, Internets und so eingebaut werden müssen. Laut gesetzlichen Vorschriften
und dann auch, wie Geheimdienste, das macht er schon immer, aber jetzt mit Bull Run und ähnlichen ähnlichen Sachen voraus den Enthüllungen, aus dem Fundus von Snowden, haben wir es ja auch wirklich hochoffiziös und es ist jetzt,
nicht mehr nur ein Aluhut Thema. Hat dann nochmal ausgeführt
wie aktuell einige NSA-Mitarbeiter, aber auch BND und GCHQ Mitarbeiter versuchen
Arbeitsgruppen der Internet Engineering Test Force ITF zu Verschlüsselungsstandards äh infiltrieren und dann auch für die verschiedenen Algorithmen, RC vier und
bis hin zu man denn jetzt nehmen soll, was jetzt alles rauskommt, was man jetzt auch mal bei Reuters und bei,
liest. Äh und früher halt nur so ein Erich Michel und Club Thema war. Und er konnte da halt jetzt wirklich nochmal äh so einen Rundumschlag machen.
Vortrag, der sonst so nur auf einen Kongress hätte äh stattfinden können. Ja, bisher. Und jetzt halt auch auf der Republika.
Ja, wobei,
ich bin ja auch bei der Republika ein bisschen befangen, Bildung über Netzpolitik äh offiziell bei Newthinking GmbH eingestellt, die ja diesen mal mit gegründet hat und mein
Mitarbeiterchef Markus, der ist ja nun einer der vier Gründer äh und auch in den vergangenen Republikas schon vor Snowden hat gerade durch die äh
ja Markus Interessensgebiet und sein Themengebiet die Netzpolitik schon immer ein hohes Thema gehabt und ich weiß auch nicht, ob das das allererste Mal war, dass Erik bei äh dass Erich bei einer Republika war, der hätte auch vorher schon hingepasst. Jetzt darf er natürlich nicht fehlen.
Ja, ich meinte das jetzt auch vor allem mehr, dadurch, dass auch die Republika selber einen ganz anderen Wahrnehmungsgrad hat mittlerweile in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit,
wirkt es natürlich auch für diese Themen nochmal als weiterer äh Geschmacksverstärker, äh während das ja vor acht Jahren noch so, ah ja, hier die Blogger und so, wollen jetzt auch Geld verdienen.
Blogger. Journalisten und wie es Pfefe damals schrieb Synchron Twitter wichsen. Erinnerst du dich, das war die zweite oder so wat, ewig her, dafür ist es, darüber sind wir heute auch lange hinaus.
Es bessert sich. Nichtsdestotrotz Republika auf jeden Fall 'ne Empfehlung wert wer 'ne gute Ausrede braucht mal so im Mai nach Berlin zu kommen,
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine. Einen Vortrag möchte ich noch äh anschließen. Der,
gewisser Hinsicht hier noch mit so reinpasst und zwar von äh Teresa äh Brücker äh besser bekannt als Fräulein Tessa.
Die ähm über Aktivismus an sich äh gesprochen hat und vor allem auch diese Burnout
Phänomene. Also, dass Leute sich einfach im Aktivismus, das bezog sich jetzt gar nicht mal nur jetzt auf netzpolitische, sondern allgemein, auch Feminismus, andere
Segmente, ja, also wie auch so die Community selbst zerstörend wirken kann dabei, was für Phänomene dort äh auftreten und was man auch dagegen tun kann. Also wirklich ein sehr nachdenklicher
oder nachdenklich machender Talk, wie ich finde, halbe Stunde kann man sich schnell mal geben, sehr.
Ähm sehr wichtiger Einblick, den sie da gibt in ihre Gedankenwelt.
So einen letzten will ich dann aber auch nochmal trocken. Und zwar hatten wir ähm.
Andre soll darauf im Programm entdeckt. Ein russischer investigativer Journalist,
schon viel zur Überwachung und Zensur und Geheimdiensten allgemein in Russland recherchiert hat, den wir auch schon äh auf dem neunundzwanzig C drei eingeladen haben,
ähm und der, ja, ich habe den dann,
wir haben den dann nochmal einen eigenen Slot gegeben auf eine dieser kleinen Bühnen, weil wir viel zu spät festgestellt hatten, dass er auch da ist, weil der.
Du warst auch im Content, im Content-Team mit dabei.
Nee, ich war im Content-Team nicht mit dabei, aber Markus und ich haben festgestellt, ui, der ist da, Andre ist wichtig. Also, wenn.
Den da nochmal reingekämpft sozusagen.
Content Team. Es gab in diesen kleinen Bühnen,
sechs bis zehn oder so was. Äh da gab's noch ein bisschen paar Platzhalter für Spontan entstehende Sachen, wo dann auch zensurheberrecht mit reingekommen ist,
und eben an drei Soldaten auf der nochmal über die politische Situation in Russland,
in Bezug auf Überwachung, Zensur und Internet, ganz allgemein eingegangen ist. Den kann ich empfehlen, der hat was zu sagen. Ich habe
dann auch das Intro für ihn gemacht und habe ihn als dessen Russlands eingeführt. Der war erst ein bisschen verwirrt, aber hat das dann fand das dann doch ganz in Ordnung und mit dem habe ich auch noch einen Podcast gemacht, eine Stunde äh vorher,
Wenn wir jetzt schon einmal beim Truppen sind, dann verlinken wir den Flash auch nochmal.
Podcast im Rahmen welches Format ist.
Äh Netzpolitik Podcast können wir verlinken, eine Stunde über die äh ja wie bezeichnet er das äh,
die deutsche Übersetzung im Titel auf Netzpolitik gepostet, äh dass die Situation für Medien Journalismus allgemein.
Der auch aufgezeichnet worden oder? Wird dann wahrscheinlich nur als Audioaufzeichnung.
Den Talk, den
sollte es eigentlich auf Audio geben, den hatte ich auch verlinkt, irgendwie ist das Audio jetzt leider wieder weg, ich finde aber in dem Podcast sind wir nochmal über den Talk hinaus gegangen, der Tag war auch noch eine halbe Stunde da äh Podcast eine Stunde,
wenn ich das Audio finde, verlinke ich's auch noch. Ansonsten erstmal den Podcast.
Verzweifelt. Die Lage ist verzweifelt, hat er gesagt, über Medien und Journalismus und die Öffentlichkeit allgemein.
Status. Meldung, vor allem, wenn wir heute wieder über Twitter, Zensur in Russland reden und so.
Ja lesen, reden tun wir da heute nicht drüber, aber.
Genau, wir haben auch noch ein paar andere Themen, da müssen wir jetzt auch mal zum Punkt kommen. Äh.
Wie hältst du's denn mit Google? Ich würde sagen, ich habe da jetzt.
Ich würde sagen, ich habe da dasselbe gespaltene Verhältnis wie ähm so viele auch, denke ich. Genau. Sag mal, worum's geht.
Lass uns doch erstmal sagen worum es geht. Genau. Ich dachte, ich meine, so schöne Überleitung zu dir.
Ja gut, also der Europäische Gerichtshof, der äh hier jüngst äh und auch vorhin nochmal für seine Entscheidung zum Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung erwähnt und gelobt wurde, hat äh jetzt eine weitere
Entscheidung gefällt und ist entgegen seinen üblichen Tendenzen hat er sich nicht wirklich
direkt an dem orientiert, was der Staatsanwalt, der europäische Staatsanwalt vorher so äh als,
Empfehlung äh abgegeben hat. Das kann man ja auch positiv sehen, ja. Die Richter denken da selber, scheint aber so ein wenig über das Ziel hinaus,
zu sein. Der Ursprung der ganzen Geschichte war die Klage eines Spaniers, der ähm,
unzufrieden war mit der Situation, dass Google Ergebnisse äh über ihn ausspuckt von Webseiten, wo er eben wohl auch tatsächlich,
genannt wird in einem.
Es geht um uralte Zeitungsarchive aus den Neunzigern von einer Lokalzeitung, die berichtet hat, dass ein Grund
oder anderes Eigentum, was ihnen gehört
gefändet wurde oder so, dass er da irgendwie eine Art Insolvenz war, was aber mittlerweile schon längst wieder verjährt ist und er sich auch in keiner finanziell komischen Situation mehr befindet. Was aber.
Wenn man seinen Namen bei der,
Suchmaschine, die es da draußen gibt, eingibt. Immer noch eins der ersten Resultate ist, ebenso ein Lokalzeitung aus dem, ich glaube, Baskengland, aus den Neunzigern, wo halt drin steht, er wäre pleite. Und damit war er ein bisschen unzufrieden.
Ja, aber es war ja nicht so, dass diese Aussage falsch gewesen wäre, sondern das war halt damals so und das ist halt noch in so einem Archiv und das Archiv
tut halt das, was so ein Archiv so macht und sagt halt, das war mal so
irgendwie scheint aber so diese Reaktion, oh Gott, ich gebe meinen Namen bei Google ein und der Google schmeißt jetzt irgendwie diesen Aspekt raus, aber erzählt nicht nebenbei noch, äh was ich für ein toller,
äh das verwirrt die dann irgendwie nachhaltig. Da wurde da halt irgendwie geklagt und auf Umwegen ist das eben bis zum EuGH gewandert und der EuGOH hat jetzt äh eine Entscheidung gefällt, die sehr vielschichtig war und ich muss sagen, ich habe mir jetzt das Urteil nicht
durchgelesen, aber im Kern wurde jetzt Google verpflichtet, dass ähm ja, solche Einträge.
In dem Fall quasi auf private Initiative eines einzelnen dann auch zu löschen sei, weil äh das ja dann eben im Kontext Datenschutz das Richtige wäre,
weil wir müssen ja unsere Daten schützen und überhaupt und die Privatsphäre und auf einmal ist das alles ganz wichtig. Und ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck,
Wenn's um Google geht, haben alle so einen Schaum vorm Mund. Und verwechseln dabei einfach.
Zwei Sachen oder mindestens zwei Sachen miteinander. Es gibt halt so Google als unser Freund und Helfer im Sinne von,
Naja äh ist es ja, ja, also ich meine, wir benutzen es den ganzen Tag, egal wie man dazu äh stehen mag. Es gibt natürlich auch einzelne, die das
auch nicht tun und da äh andere Alternativen haben, aber sie sind halt einfach bei Leiten,
und sie haben sie ja diese Marktführerschaft auch erarbeitet. Also man kann Google nicht gerade vorwerfen, dass sie äh ein schlechtes Produkt machen würden,
Ähm nur die dadurch entstandene Dominanz,
und die äh Monopol-Haft wirkende Präsenz in dem äh Marktsuchmaschinen. Und damit eben auch so dieses Bild von
des Omnipräsenten und äh vielleicht auch omnipotenten Datensammlers, der ist ja oft nichts anderes ausge äh,
angelegt hat als irgendwie alles über uns zu wissen, was im Übrigen bezweifle, aber kann man auch auf jeden Fall mal so darstellen.
Dass man da, dass daraus einfach eine Angst entsteht, die jetzt hier für vieles so ein Leitmotiv wird, wo es eben nicht angemessen ist. Man hat das irgendwie,
Leistungsschutzrecht gesehen und man sieht es eben jetzt auch in dieser Debatte. Die eben,
So sehe ich das und ich teile da die äh Eloquent von Thomas Stadler äh veröffentlichte Meinungen dazu,
Dass das eben ein sehr problematisches Urteil ist, weil wir ja im Prinzip hier ähm ja, ein,
Ein Zensurinstrument geschaffen wurde, was vergleichbar ist, ich glaube den Vergleich zieht er auch ähm mit dieser Debatte im Urheberrechtsbereich, wo halt äh ja auch schon unglaublich viele Links auch Suchmaschinen entfernt werden,
Ja, auf Anfrage von Rechteinhabern und das ist halt da jetzt äh einen weiteren Hebel gibt, einfach,
etwas aus Suchmaschinen zu entfernen ohne dass er die eigentlichen Quellen, die ja existieren.
Der Grund für diesen Eintrag sind, verschwinden.
So, das heißt, Dinge gibt es, aber sie werden nicht sichtbar gemacht und da sind wir ja im Prinzip auch schon wieder mitten in unserer guten, alten Zensursula-Debatte,
So, jetzt darfst du.
So, erstmal muss ich einen riesen, fetten Display mal voranschicken. Ich habe das Urteil zwar gelesen, aber.
Nicht verstanden.
Naja, wir hatten das schon oft, wenn's um solche Themen geht, ihr Anal, wir sind beides keine Jurist.
Ja, ja, genau, so bin ich.
Ich hoffe, große, weite Teile der.
Der Begründung des Gerichts verstanden zu haben, komplett sehe ich weder durch die juristischen Hintergründe und ich glaube wenige Leute.
Glücklicherweise ein paar von denen, die hier bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik schon zu Gast waren, haben die Datenschutzgesetzgebung der EU vollständig verstanden.
Was dazu ganz hilfreich aber ist. Und ich muss jetzt in dieser Debatte,
so ein bisschen den spielen. Das heißt, ich sage nicht nur unbedingt meine Meinung, sondern auch die Position, die hier mal gesagt werden muss, denn natürlich,
sehe ich die Gefahr. Auch von Stadler. Aber man ist, um mal das Urteil ein bisschen aufzudröseln, ohne es komplett ausufernd zu machen. Es gab ja mehrere Bestandteile äh der Begründung des Gerichtes. Das erste war,
Google hat sich in nicht nur diesem Prozess, sondern allen anderen, wie immer,
versucht komplett aus der Affäre zu ziehen und haben gesagt, europäische Gesetzgebung, damit haben wir nichts am Hut. Wir sind eine Firma in Kalifornien. Das hat das Gericht verneint.
Und zwar Google Spanien, betreibt ja verkauft Werbung und nimmt ein Haufen Umsatz für Google ein,
Genauso wie Google Deutschland hat hier 'ne Niederlassung, ist hier ansprechbar und wo genau die Daten verarbeitet werden, was ja in der Welt der Cloud sowieso gar nicht mehr zu klären ist heutzutage, ist für diese Entscheidung des Gerichts irrelevant.
Wenn Google hier eine Niederlassung hat und hier Geld verdient, dann muss es sich auch an Gesetze hier halten.
Genau, das stimmt, das Peter, die auch ehrlich gesagt jetzt äh gerade ausgeblendet gehabt, das ist nachvollziehbar. Wenn man das ja auch das erste Mal eigentlich, dass das so kommt.
Das ist, das ist das erste Mal, dass das so konkret ähm europäische Gesetzgebung gesagt wird. Das hat zwei Aspekte. Das eine ist äh Geld.
Und zwar wir kommen da nochmal kurz auf das Handelsblatt nicht nur ist Google,
also der größte Werbevermarkte der Welt,
mit ein paar angeschlossenen Diensten wie äh Internet, Zugmaschine und äh größtem mobilen Betriebssystem und so weiter und so fort, was aber die Werbeindustrie komplett in den Schatten stellt, was der eigentliche Kern des Umsatzes von Google ist.
Das wird aber,
Ja, so viele Steuern kommen weder in Deutschland, noch der EU an. Es gibt da Recherchen, dass Google wie andere große Firmen und auch andere große Internetfirmen diverseste Steuertricks benutzt vom.
Mit,
Sandwich und dann zu den Bermudas und so weiter, äh Gelder leitet, um im Endeffekt zu wenig Steuern wie möglich zu zahlen.
Was aus ihrer ureigenen kapitalistischen Interesse verständlich ist, aber als gesamtgesellschaft,
wirklich die äh Einigung, die wir erzielt haben, um große Firmen, Umsätze, die Wirtschaft auch an der Gesellschaft zu beteiligen. Also das.
Man das wahrscheinlich auch diesen Firmen selber nicht so unmittelbar zur Last legen kann, weil,
Es ist ja dann legal. Alle anderen machen's auch, um um ihre Wettbewerbsfähigkeit da zu halten. Es ist klar, dass sie sich dann auch genauso verhalten, äh wie die anderen, das Problem muss,
einer anderen Ebene gelöst werden.
Jetzt haben wir zum allerersten Mal die Ansage, nee, wenn du hier Geld verdienst,
dann bist du hier auch einerseits für die Steuergesetze verantwortlich und dann müssen wir mal noch sehen wie sich das jetzt entwickelt die Politik jetzt einmal darauf aufmerksam worden ist das Google sich an,
auch europäische Gesetzgebung halten muss. Und der zweite Punkt ist natürlich, wenn Google hier rechtlich verantwortlich ist, dann nicht nur für Steuergesetzgebung, sondern für alles mögliche an Gesetzgebung, wo,
zu eben unter anderem der Datenschutz zählt. Wir hatten das bisher, ziehen sich Facebook und Google und viele andere ähm,
Große Internetkonzerne darauf zurück, in Niederlassung in Irland zu haben, wo rein zufälligerweise nicht nur,
günstige Steuervorkommen äh Steuervorgaben sind, sondern auch das Datenschutzrecht in der EU,
und weder Google Deutschland noch Facebook Deutschland wollen sich ein deutsches Datenschutzgesetz halten, die sagen, wenn ihr schon in der EU uns an irgendein EU-Gesetz halten müsst, dann ja, wo dann das Ihrische.
Das hat das Gericht jetzt auch verneint,
das ist sinnvoll aus der Perspektive von Datenschutz. Und ich glaube, alle Leute, mit denen wir über die europäische Datenschutzverordnung äh und auch Bundesdatenschutzgesetz reden, finden das einen großen Gewinn.
Das hat die beiden Vorteile, das hat aber auch Nachteile, unter anderem, wie ich mit Andrej Soldat auf gesprochen habe,
Es ist ja schön, dass wir in Europa gutes Steuer und Datenschutzrecht haben und sich Google und Facebook
Ist hierzulande an unsere in unseren Augen besseren Gesetze als in den USA zu richten haben. Das ist aber auch eine Steilvorlage für andere Länder wie Russland, die dann sagen, ja da müsst ihr euch aber auch in unsere Gesetze in Russland halten oder Iran und China und so weiter und so fort.
Was ja aber de facto ohnehin schon tun.
Was in allen Staaten der Welt jetzt eine Auseinandersetzung geworden ist in den letzten Jahren. Mal mehr, mal weniger. Das geht dann bis hin zu wenn du hier einen Dienst betreibst, musst du auch die Server hier haben.
Dann unsere Geheimdienste und polizeilichen Zugriffe haben, dass wir an die Markus Siguda Internet in Brasilien, das war die Diskussion von
äh und das würde voller Russland auch gerade von Facebook und so. Das ist alles noch nicht ausgefochten. Ist ja auch eine riesige Debatte. Wie funktioniert Governance,
die bisher allgemein politisch noch meistens nationalstaatlich geregelt ist, in so etwas supernationalem wie dem.
Aber ich glaube, ich glaube aber jetzt nicht, dass der Iran und Russland jetzt unbedingt darauf gewartet haben, dass der EuGH jetzt irgendwie eine Entscheidung zur europäischer Gesetzgebung äh macht, bevor sie äh das durchsetzen, was sie gerne durchsetzen wollen würden, das tun sie ohnehin.
Das nicht, aber Andre soll eben gemeint, immer wenn in deutscher Politiker sagt, ja wir wollen, dass die sich an unsere Gesetze halten, sagen die Russen, seht ihr? Die wollen das auch, ist gar nicht so schlimm,
Haben wir auch in China ein bisschen so in haben mir auch die Chinesen gesagt, ey guckt mal, sogar Deutschland sensiert das Internet.
Ja ja.
Einen zweiten Punkt, äh um den es in dem Urteil ging, ist, es es geht jetzt nicht,
irgendwie unmittelbar um Urheberrechtsverstöße oder irgendwelche anderen Inhalte äh der Wahl, sondern konkret um personenbezogene Daten,
darauf, das war die komplette Frage hinter dem Urteil, das ist jetzt nicht so allgemein für alle Datentypen im Netz auslegbar und.
Mark auf den ersten Blick absurd erscheinen und das finde ich auch, wenn ein spanisch das Gericht sagt, dass Zeitungsarchiv ist legal,
Google dazu verpflichten, den Link darauf wegzunehmen. Das ist absurd. So funktioniert Internet nicht. Darauf können wir uns einigen. Wenn man aber mal einen Schritt weiterdenkt.
Tatsächlich haben wir da draußen als öffentlich bestimmte Datentypen, wie zum Beispiel Facebook, Posts und Profileinstellungen.
Die eine bestimmte Form der Öffentlichkeit haben,
wo aber nicht immer den und das juristische Begriff Datensubjekten, den Leuten, der äh um dessen Daten das geht, die komplette.
Außenwirkung bewusst sein kann. Wir haben Beispiele davon äh es gibt Studien, die aus Facebookprofilen,
herausarbeiten, welche äh Inhaber von Profilen, Homosexuell sind und welche nicht,
sich nicht unmittelbar aus den Angaben, die die ihnen im Profil oder was ihre Freunde sagen machen, sondern allein von dem sozialen Netzwerk, in dem sie sich bewegen,
tatsächlich gibt es heutzutage Daten und die ganze Big Data Diskussion ist auch so ein riesen Fass, was noch lange nicht ausgestanden ist, da werden noch einige äh Fetzen fliegen und Entwicklungen uns einholen,
ähm nur weil die Staaten an einer wie auch immer geartete private, unmittelbare Öffentlichkeit auf Facebook stelle, bin ich dann damit einverstanden, dass automatisch irgendjemand anderes automatisch alles jemals damit machen kann?
Wir haben in der Geschichte Beispiele gehabt, wo ich persönlich Regierungen und auch äh Wirtschaft und auch nicht immer jeder Forschung erlauben würde. Ja, ihr könnt jetzt,
Das ganze Netz gräben und da draus listen aus äh ja Homosexuellen,
Mit anderer Religion oder politische Diszidenten rauszufiltern, äh da finde ich schon, dass man in von öffentlichen Daten in einem in einer zweiten Datenverarbeitungsschritt.
Schon nochmal andere Regeln aufsetzen kann. Das hat das Gericht gemacht. Das Gericht hat jetzt nicht gesagt, der Link an sich ist illegal, äh sondern,
Google ist Datenverarbeiter, der
äh Link nicht nur im Internet rum, sondern Google archiviert auch einmal das Internet, aber im Gegensatz zu dot org, äh stellt der das nicht wieder komplett öffentlich zur Verfügung, sondern nur in seiner internen Datenbank, läuft da, lässt da drüber intransparente Algorithmen äh laufen, hat aber die Daten
äh und erstellt somit etwas komplett, also etwas Neues, was über den eigentlichen Inhalt herausgeht,
Sascha Lobo hat das zurecht kritisiert, dass äh dass eine Entscheidung zwischen äh Öffentlichkeit, das was in der Zeitung steht,
und einer erweiterten Öffentlichkeit aufmacht, die dadurch zustande kommt, was man bei Google eingibt und dann unter den Top Ten äh zu finden ist,
Diese äh ja Entscheidung ist wiederum Demokratie theoretisch höchst fragwürdig, dass jetzt
das relevante ist, was in Google Suchergebnis an äh gezeigt wird und juristisch anders zu bewerten ist, als in der Zeitung steht. Unter den Gesichtspunkten von Big Data Studien aber.
Haben wir da eine offene Diskussion, wo ich finde, wir noch in keiner Weise zufriedenstellende Antworten haben.
Da müssen wir uns in Zukunft damit auseinandersetzen. Das Gericht hat das Fass mit aufgemacht. Google wurde auch nicht verpflichtet, ähm.
Ja, Google wurde im Endeffekt dazu verpflichtet, sie dürfen diese Daten, glaube ich, verarbeiten,
Sie dürfen nur den Link nicht anzeigen. Was ja richtig cool gewesen wäre, wäre, wenn das spanische Gericht gesagt hätte, na klar darfst du Zeitung das veröffentlichen. Aber ey, es gibt hier so einen Meta-Tag, der nennt sich No Index.
Wie wär's wenn du das reinmachst?
Dann hätten wir da wenigstens, wir sind ein Nerds, wir denken auf technisch, ähm dass technisch geregelt und so eine Robots Text auch mal gerichtlich geklärt, was ja bis heute
nicht so wirklich gerichtsfest ist und auch bei Leistungsschutzrecht immer hin und her ging oder
das wäre eine Lösung, mit der wir akzeptabler lesen können. Eines der Hintergründe der Entscheidung ist aber, das Gericht hat jetzt nicht umfassend tatsächlich alle Aspekte,
alle Auswirkungen, die das haben, könnte geprüft, sondern die Richte meistens nur sind, die nehmen die drei Fragen, die in ihnen gegeben wurde und bearbeiten die Fragen. Das hat jetzt keine,
gesamtgesellschaftlich gültige, zukünftige Regelungen mit Suchmaschinen und personenbezogene Daten an sich geliefert, sondern um die Fälle, um um dies da ging.
Und ja, zum nächsten Punkt, dass du auch so,
Google ähm als mit Suchmaschine gleichgesetzte kommen wir dann bestimmt gleich nochmal, äh wenn wir über die Reaktionen der Politik
darauf kommen. Äh so ist das ja auch nicht. Aber ich habe jetzt, glaube ich, ein paar Punkte aufgemacht, wo,
hoffentlich, ich meine störler hat nicht unrecht. Nimm nicht auf einen legalen Inhalt lenken zu dürfen, geht nicht im Internet.
Aber wir müssen uns tatsächlich diese wichtigen Fragen stellen. Äh soll,
Google sich ein deutsches Recht halten, soll Google sich ein deutsches Datenschutzrecht aus äh halten oder ein europäisches, wieso europäisches Datenschutzrecht aussehen und so eine Perspektiven von,
Gibt es wirklich Sachen, die man aus öffentlichen Daten generieren kann, wo der äh ursprüngliche Verwendungszweck äh nicht mehr gegeben ist.
Ein Beispiel, was es auch trifft, sind diese bescheuerten Personensuchmaschinen. Ich weiß nicht, wie genau die alle heißen. Jasmin und so,
Das ist der letzte Rotz im Internet, der bitte sterben soll und ich hoffe, dieses Urteil ist ein Ansatz, diese mal anzugehen. Also es gibt ja nicht nur Google als Suchmaschine da draußen.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ja, interessanter äh Aspekt, vor allem auch die Sichtweise, so ähm auch das Suchen und Bereitstellen quasi als äh wirklich schon als gehobene Datenverarbeitung zu empfinden, was es ja ist. Also weil einfach diese in Bezugssätzerei
Ist natürlich schon eine äh Reinterpretation, das stimmt.
Also grad dieser Vergleich mit, der kam natürlich dann auch schnell auf im Netz, so nach dem Motto, ja, da ist ja irgendwie alles immer noch zu finden und so, aber es geht hier nicht so sehr um.
Die machen keine neue Verarbeitung.
Genau, also es ist eine Bereitstellung der der Quelle, die man explizit äh suchen kann,
ähm Google stellt Bezüge her und äh gut, das ist äh eine, wie findet eine legitime Diskussion hier eben auch darüber zu sprechen, was für Bezüge.
Hergestellt werden dürfen.
Das ist,
Schlagwort seit drei Jahren, da haben wir noch lange keine befriedigende Antworten, weder als Gesellschaft noch als Netzcommunity dafür gefunden, müssen wir weiter nachdenken. Brain Power investieren. Mir ist noch ein Punkt
zu dem Hotel eingefallen, der jetzt sich aber schon wieder verflüchtigt hat.
Sigmar Gabriel hat sich ja irgendwie auch äh zu Wort gemeldet zu dem Thema, aber ich habe den äh interessant, dass er jetzt von einem Betriebssystem äh.
Ja, lass uns, lass uns die lass uns die Politik,
Ähm mal gleich machen. Also du merkst, ich tue mich schwer mit eindeutigen äh Beurteilungen. Es hat tatsächlich, wie ich finde,
positive Aspekte. Es birgt aber auch die Gefahr,
Ähm es darf auf keinen Fall sich auf äh Meinungsinformationsfreiheit auswirken. Und als Netzcommunity sind das natürlich sowohl Datenschutz als auch äh,
keine Zensur, Kernthemen,
Ich finde, wir sollten die nicht so einfach gegeneinander ausspielen, sondern selbst äh zukunftsweisende Positionen entwickeln, die beide Sachen beinhalten. Ah ja, ist mir wieder eingefallen, worauf ich gerade noch hinaus wollte. Es ist ja jetzt auch nicht
das allererste Mal, dass Google zu so etwas gezwungen wird,
im Februar vom Landgericht Hamburg äh das unsere Spezialexperten,
von dem, was wir ja, glaube ich, Formel-eins-Typ oder so, Max Moslee, äh,
Bilder aus der Bildersuche entfernt werden muss. Wir hatten das Urteil von Bettina Wulf, die nicht wollte, dass wenn man Bettina Wolf in der Google Suche eingibt, die Autoverständigung mit angezeigt wird, die hat auch recht bekommen.
Ähm da hat die Netzcommunity nicht so einen Aufschrei gemacht. Dann haben wir sekündlich,
löscht Google Suchergebnisse auf angebliche Urheberrechtsverletzung. Das ist ein riesen äh Thema, wo wir viel aktiver sein sollten. Das das da geht's nicht um personenbezogene Daten. Da geht's um angebliche Urheberrechtsverletzungen mit
automatisierten Systeme da entscheiden Algorithmen äh mit jede Menge Falls positives und das nimmt also das insüdlich mehrere, das.
Das sind Millionen, noch viel mehr. Und in Deutschland haben wir ja gerade die Position, äh hier wird,
nicht Meinungsfreiheit, sondern hier werden Gesetze anders ausgelegt als in den Staaten. Wenn man hier zum Beispiel nach äh Nazis sucht.
Bekommt man nichts bei weitem nicht so viele Art Zuckergebnisse, wie in den Staaten,
das Verwenden verfassungswidrige Organisationen und Symbole kennzeichnen ist hier illegal,
in den Staaten, die kennen sowas nicht. Wir hatten schon in den Neunzigern Diskussionen um Seiten wie Rotten dot com und Stonefriend dot org. Ähm
es scheint sich ein gesellschaftlicher Konsens in Deutschland entwickelt zu haben, auch wenn's so ein paar letzte Reste von Netzgemeinde gibt, die sie auch dagegen noch argumentieren, dass bestimmte Anpassungen von Suchergebnissen in bestimmten Staaten,
Zumindest jetzt nicht der Untergang des Netzabendlandes sind.
Hm.
Das nochmal zur Einordnung von dem ganzen Ding.
So wirst du jetzt immer noch komplett bei Stadler.
Nö, würde ich jetzt nicht äh so sagen, aber ich finde, ich finde die Debatte äh ganz spannend, weil es einfach auch mal einen neuen äh Aspekt äh beinimmt. Aber wie gesagt, ich hatte das Urteil noch nicht äh gelesen, mir waren jetzt diese,
Aspekte machen, auch überhaupt gar nicht äh klar geworden, dass jetzt zum Beispiel diese Zuständigkeits äh Regelung damit auch das erste Mal neu umgedeutet worden ist.
So und dann ist die Woche von Google ausgebrochen. Jeder und sein Hund hat sich dann mal zum Urteil geäußert, nicht nur in der Netzcommunity, sondern jetzt mittlerweile auch in der Politik.
Du hattest schon angesprochen, die Bundesregierung sucht die Politik eines neuen Betriebssystems. Gestern sind unsere drei Internetminister,
am selben Tag ich wir fragen uns immer noch ob das so koordiniert war oder nicht haben sich zu Wort gemeldet in Wirtschaftsminister.
Die drei Weisen des,
politischen Morgenlandes haben sich auf den Weg gegeben, um einem Stern zu folgen.
Ja, Sigmar Gabriel hat gleich die erste Seite von bekommen.
Ähm Wirtschaftsminister, der Innenminister de Maizire hat einen Interview um Handelsblatt gegeben,
und dann hat Verkehrsminister Dobrindt äh noch in, was war das wieder in der Welt, glaube ich, nachgelegt. Und alle mussten jetzt mal irgendwas,
da passiert gerade was mit Google und Internet und wir müssen jetzt auch mal unseren Senf dazugeben.
Und dann haben wir diese Interviews zu gelesen und äh Debattenbeiträge ist sind tatsächlich einige okay Positionen dabei, aber im Großen und Ganzen blieb das ein bisschen,
Waage, denn großen Einschlag hat natürlich erstmal Sigmar Gabriel in der Faz gemacht.
Ich glaube, das ist der Titel, äh die äh ein die Politik eines neuen Betriebssystems auf der SPD DE Seite steht da nämlich was anderes drüber.
Ja.
Haben die Eigenart Titel zu ändern.
Ja, gerne machen sie das.
Unter anderem.
Aber der selbe Text oder was der da jetzt.
Glaube ich, dass also das sollte identisch sein, man könnte da mal ein machen, wäre vielleicht auch spannend. Ich weiß nicht, ob's schon online ist, auf wir hatten das nur im Print, in.
Ja, war es war es, ich muss es mal kurz suchen.
Ja und da hat sein Redenschreiber erstmal von sich gegeben, dass er auch alle anderen Beiträge zum Thema gelesen hat, was man glaube ich so machen muss,
Und dann versucht zu erklären, dass außer Google ist böse, was man jetzt mit diesem Internet alles machen muss. Also.
Den Titel finde ich jetzt hier ehrlich gesagt so nicht hier, heißt's unsere politischen Konsequenzen aus der Google-Debatte.
Ja wir hatten gestern die Printausgabe da stand das die Politik eines neuen Betriebssystems ganz groß in Roth.
Verstehe, also die Printredaktion hat da was anderes geändert, als.
Lustig, ne? Ich meine, auf SPD DE sein Titel, auf ist ein Tipp.
Hat wahrscheinlich dann nochmal den den SEO aus dem Schrank geholt so. Nee, Betriebssystem und so weiter, damit kriegen wir keine Hits.
Danach sucht heute keiner mehr.
Ja ganz bezeichnend fanden wir in der Netzpolitik auch Redaktion, nachdem wir diesen Text einmal quer und einmal nochmal detailliert gelesen hat, er geht mit keinem Wort,
Auf den Späßskandal ein. Das Wort NSA kommt nicht vor, das Wort BND kommt nicht vor. Edward Snowden kommt nicht vor, Überwachung durch Geheimdienste kommt nicht vor.
Also er versucht jetzt politische Konsequenzen. Na hier ist es Demokratie eines neuen Betriebssystems. Die Demokratie im digitalen Zeitalter, also tatsächlich so etwas wie eine netzpolitische Grundsatzposition.
Er meint, wer heute Mitte vierzig oder älter ist, hat als Teenager keine Mails geschrieben. Hallo!
Da habe ich sofort an dich gedacht. Genau, das ist, glaube ich, auch gleich der erste Satz. Na ja, ich habe gleich gesagt, der Tim wird sich freuen.
Oh Mann.
Genau, da da gibt's noch ein paar so eine Bonbons.
Ja, ich meine, ich will ja gar nicht sagen, dass er nicht grundsätzlich schon Recht hätte, ja. Facebook habe ich damals wirklich nicht benutzt, äh, ob das nun wirklich jetzt entscheidend ist, weiß ich nicht. Aber egal.
Ja. Und jetzt.
Ja, ich meine, dass er da jetzt nicht auf NSR ein, den wir überrascht dich das, dass er äh da diesen Bezug nicht herstellt. Es.
Wenn's um Google geht nicht, aber wenn er tatsächlich in der Netzpolitik als Internetminister eine netzpolitische Grundsatzposition auf einem einseitigen äh aufn Ganzzeit darstellt, ist es schon ganz schön peinlich, dass ihm in keinem Wort zu erwähnen.
Ja. Internetminister. Ja was denn mit den anderen Heiligen, Dreikönigen? Also.
Ja, lass uns mal nach zwei Sätze, also wir machen heute mal lang, aber noch zwei Sätze zu Gabriel sagen, er hat unter anderem äh die Frage aufgeworfen, ob,
man ja Google zu schlagen müsse, ob das Kartell an sich das mal angucken sollte und das ist tatsächlich eine Position, während äh Innenminister Maizire gesagt hat, ach, das können wir in Deutschland gar nicht. Darüber muss ich nicht nachdenken. Das kann nur die EU-Kommission
hat Gabriel das weiter unten gemacht.
Ähm Bundeswirtschaftsministerium Kartell prüfen, ob ein Unternehmen wie Google seine Markt beherrschende Stellung missbraucht, eine Entflechtung, wie sie bei Strom und Gasnetzen durchgesetzt wurde, muss dabei ernsthaft erwogen werden.
Das ist ein Punkt, den finde ich diskutabel und,
Auf den ersten Blick unterstützenswert. Und da will ich eben nochmal den Punkt anführen, dass Google eben keinesfalls nur eine Suchmaschine ist.
Hast du hier irgendwie einen anderen Artikel als ich?
Auf einer Seite, sechs Seiten.
Ach super.
Froh, dass keine Klickstrecke draus geworden ist.
Genau, Strom und Gasnetze da.
Mhm.
Und tatsächlich ist Google eben hunderte, tausende verschiedene Dienste und der größte Werbevermarkter der Welt.
Tatsächlich das Kerneigene Suchgeschäft,
von YouTube, von der Werbevermarktung, von Android und den tausend anderen Sachen, die unter dem Google Banner noch zusammen sind, zu entflechten.
Tja, viel Spaß.
Ist ja, dass es einfach ach, es hat niemand gesagt, äh finde ich aber politisch eine sinnvolle Forderung. Dann haben wir,
unter anderem äh verklagt Deutschland immer wieder Google, weil die Zusammenführung äh der Nutzerdaten von sämtlichen Services,
bei Google zu in ein Profil mal so gemacht wurde und das geht, glaube ich, weder nach EU, noch nach Bundesdatenschutzrecht,
Da kann man jetzt sagen, okay, die sind nicht hier, aber da sind wir wieder bei der Debatte, die wir vorhin aufgemacht haben. Wollen wir das?
Gibt auch keine einfache Antwort, aber ich finde, dass eine Forderung, über die wir nachdenken. Zurecht haben wir Regeln, eben im Strom- und Gasnetz und auch Eisenbahn und so
man darf nicht gleichzeitig 'n ja,
Betreiber der Züge der Bahnhöfe, der Eigentümer der Schienen und noch so weiter sein, sonst ist man ein Monopol. Man hat das.
Gut, aber es ist immer schnell gesagt, äh Google zu Monopolisten zu erheben, was sie aber auch einfach mal,
bestenfalls in in einigen Ländern sind, aber beileibe nicht äh in allen, als es auch durchaus belegbar, dass,
auch sehr wohl mit normalen äh normale Marktkräfte ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig, wenn's um äh China und Russland geht, aber,
Ich gehe da gleich mal wieder einen halben Schritt zurück. Trotz alledem äh äh ich halte es durchaus vorstellbar, auch wenn man sich das immer nicht,
so recht vorstellen kann, ja, dass die Dinge sich auch genauso schnell wieder ändern können, wenn einfach die Vorzeichen äh sich ändern.
Ich wünsche es mir aber, weißt du überhaupt, wie die europäische Suchmaschine, die seit zehn Jahren diskutiert wird? Heißt, kannst du mir jetzt den Namen von dem Projekt? Na siehst du.
Eure wahrscheinlich.
Und ehrlich, schon mal schon mal gebingt und oder gejaht in den letzten zehn Jahren, außer zu Testzwecken.
Ja, man ich google ja auch nur zu Testswecken.
Genau.
Teste, ob ich das finden kann oder nicht. Ja gut, aber wie gesagt, das ist nicht so, dass ich Google benutze, weil weil es mir vorgeschrieben wird und ich keine andere Wahl hätte.
Ja so ich ich habe ja die Wahl und ich tue es ja deshalb nicht an anderen Orten, weil ich mit dem Ergebnis nicht so zufrieden bin.
Nun das halte ich nur für halblausibel.
Google hat sich damals übrigens über diese Qualität auch durchgesetzt.
Natürlich, das weiß ich auch noch damals als Google wirklich noch cool und hip und not evil war gegen Altarvista und so, aber.
Einer der letzten verbleibenden, die nicht bei Facebook sind,
und es ist echt schwer. Und es ist nicht so, dass ich äh dass ich alle freiwillig entscheiden dorthin zu gehen, weil die den besten Service haben, sondern wir sehen dann eben die Effekte, äh die Masseneffekte, wo einmal die Masse ist, da geht die Masse hin und da geht sie schwer wieder weg,
passiert im Netz. Und genau das haben wir bei Google auch,
Google ist hat einmal durchgezogen, ist groß geworden. Die haben jetzt so viel Geld gegen, also da kann keine
staatliche Förderung bisher die ernsthaft angedacht wurde, außer eventuell in dazu noch äh Wirtschaftshemmenden äh Staaten wie Jandex in Russland und China, die müssen wir schon erwähnen. Iran versucht so was Ähnliches, aber aufm freien Markt kann mit Googles Kapital einfach niemand mithalten, genauso mit der Erfahrung,
ewig die größten Serverparks, die besten Algorithmen, äh die äh
die größten Brainsie aus der ganzen Welt in ihre Forschungsabteilung abziehen mit rein marktwirtschaftlichen Kräften,
wird das schwer, dem tatsächlich was entgegen zu leisten? Ich finde, das ist eine Debatte, die man ruhig mal führen kann.
Ja, man kann die Debatte gerne führen. Da habe ich gar nichts gegen.
Den letzten Punkt, den äh äh Wirtschaftsminister noch angesprochen hat, war das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, was auch immer, dass da mit noch zu tun hat, außer, dass,
mit den Daten im Internet, dass alles schlecht war, die gehen dann äh unmittelbar zu Google
Das haben wir im letzten Jahr schon mal als Referentenentwurf gesehen äh soll, wurde auf der Cebit versprochen, jetzt noch im Sommer kommen, müssen wir mal gucken, was das genau werden wird
immer wenn die Bundesregierung was zu IT-Sicherheit macht, können wir gleich noch beim Ausschuss dazu, ist das immer mit Vorsicht zu beurteilen.
Coole Sachen, paar coole Ideen drin, wie eine Benachrichtigungspflicht bei Sicherheitsvorfällen quasi, wenn.
Deine E-Mail-Anbieter oder wenn irgendein,
Internetan, wie Serviceanbieter ähm wurde, dass du dann auch Bescheid kriegst, hier in der Marlene Passworte und so, da gibt's bissle rechtlich keine Vorgabe. Nur dem Entwurf, den wir damals gesehen haben, ähm,
sollte die Information nur an das BSI gehen,
und nicht an die Betroffenen und die Informationspflicht sollte auch nur für die Wirtschaft gelten und nicht für staatliche Stellen. Das waren also große Kritikpunkte von uns, aber,
die Wirtschaft, die Internetwirtschaft hat trotzdem geschafft diesen schwachen Vortrag äh Vorschlag äh noch als.
Unüberwindbares Handy zu einem äh ihre Pflicht äh ihre Zustimmung zu dem Gesetz,
zu kriegen. Das heißt, die haben, weil sie eben Meldepflichten für Sicherheitsvorkehrungen äh kriegen sollten. Und wenn wir es nur an das BSI ist und teilweise Wochen nach dem eigentlichen Vorfall sein kann, damals das Wirtschaftsministerium dazu gekriegt
den Gesetzvorschlag quasi einzutüten. Und das ist äh deswegen ist er nicht durchgekommen. Wir werden jetzt sehen, wenn's im Sommer einen neuen Anlauf gibt, ob's da ein paar sinnvolle Sachen drin gibt.
Gut, dann hatten wir noch de Maizire im Handelsblatt,
Ja, wurde auch auf Snowden angesprochen und hat dann irgendwie nur dazu gesagt, ja, ob,
so cool war, dass der, also dass ein Systemadministrator überhaupt so viele Daten mitnehmen kann und wie gut das jetzt war, weiß ja auch noch nicht. Es war alles, was er dazu gesagt hat und Dobrindt hat nicht ganz mithalten können mit dem Inhalten der beiden anderen, aber wir sehen.
Dem Zusammenhang auch die äh jüngst aufgekommene Debatte über die existierende Vorratsdatenspeicherung im,
tag. Ja, wo dann ja auch die Bundestagsverwaltung irgendwie so äh mit den Armen ruderte und dann irgendwie meinte so, ja, nee, das wäre alles äh äh überhaupt kein Problem, da hätten ja nur einige, wenige Admins äh vollen Zugriff drauf.
Wie war das mit der Forderung? Äh der Gläser nicht stört.
Maschinen lesbare.
Ist bei der Regierung.
Da wäre sicherlich ein Ansatz zu finden, aber ist ja leider nur das Parlament,
Ich finde, das wäre jetzt auch mal ganz interessant, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das unbedingt so der Ort so, aber die Regierung könnte man schon mal so mitspeichern und äh ja, da fehlt halt noch die API, ne. Ist eine wirklich,
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie alt diese Forderung ist, aber es geht noch auf zurück und äh von daher äh auf jeden Fall noch in zwanzigste Jahrhundert. Und das ist schon, da steckt wirklich viel,
viel, viel, viel richtiges äh drin und ich glaube, das Thema, das kommt irgendwann auch nochmal auf den Tisch.
Hoffentlich, genau wie öffentliche Daten, schützen privat äh öffentliche Daten nützen private Daten schützen, das war's auch bei dem Google Urteil wieder äh hervorzuziehen ist, was davon ist öffentlich und was davon ist jetzt privat?
Genau. Ja das passt.
Sehr weit blickend. Na ja gut, der Mann, der hier in der Meterebene hängt.
Der war auch ja ja, ich habe ja immer ein Foto von ihm. Wirklich eine äh bemerkenswerte äh Person, viele von unseren Hörern münden, vielleicht auch
gar nicht mehr kennen, also war Holland, ist ja einer so der wesentliche Gründer des äh CCs äh gewesen und auch wirklich ein,
hervorragender äh Philosoph, der also eine eine Zukunftskompatibilität am Start hatte, die mich immer wieder erschreckt hat.
Insbesondere äh wenn man so mit ihm in Real Life diskutiert hat äh,
bezog er sich dann immer in Debatten immer auf Kontexte, über die er jetzt grade redet, mit Suchbegriffen,
Das war aber zu einem Zeitpunkt, da gab es noch kein Google und diese Vorstellung von einer effizienten Suche im Netz war irgendwie,
das da war das echt noch total äh Science-Fiction. Aber äh so äh hat er das immer gemacht so. Ja äh könnt ihr alles nachlesen im,
Begriffe äh Bielefeld, Konfusion und irgendwie Datenaustausch oder was weiß ich, ja, also und äh dachte ich mir so, wovon redet der Mann eigentlich und dann erst so später wurde mir dann immer wieder klar, wie viel weit dick äh
das hat er.
Wirst du nicht nur einen CRE plaggen, wo du unter anderem die Geschichte vom Club mit umfassenderwähnung von Bau behandelt hast.
Welche meinst du denn jetzt.
Ganz genau du bist der Spezialexperte die hundert oder so.
Äh ich dachte, du beziehst dich jetzt konkret auf äh eine.
Nee, ich habe das nicht so gut im Kopf wie du.
Na gut, wenn ich plaggen soll, dann äh plag ich. Es gibt äh in der Tat ähm mindestens zwei Sendungen. Ich werde mal mich genau auf zwei äh beziehen, die so ein bisschen diese frühe Zeit. Und auch das äh Wirken von dem Zusammenhang,
beleuchtet haben, einerseits CRE null, drei, acht, eine Reise in die Vergangenheit mit Peter Glaser, der auch so,
der Frühzeit ist, das war sehr interessant, gerade so zum Entstehen des Ganzen, das war halt so anlässlich des fünfundzwanzigsten Geburtstags des CCC, da sind wir jetzt auch schon wieder ein bisschen weiter.
Und ähm dann habe ich äh zur ähm.
Äh auf der As Elektroniker mal live eine Sendung aufgenommen mit CRE hunderteinundsechzig der CCC und die Öffentlichkeit, wo dann vor allem auch diese ganzen,
Sachen noch mal mit äh Naserheck und so weiter zur Sprache kam. Da kann man noch mal reinhören,
Gut. Ja, was den Weitblick betrifft, sind ja auch die Amerikaner immer ganz weit äh vorne und äh gutes ist ja noch die Amerikaner äh gibt, die so eine gute Vorstellung vom Internet haben und äh,
die Zukunft sicherlich beschützen werden.
Genau. Netzneutralität.
Da war noch was.
Politik berichtete, äh vor drei Wochen gab's ja schon mal erste öffentliche Berichterstattungen, dass die FCC ihre neuen Netzneutralitätsregeln vorstellen möchte,
Ja und das war jetzt am Donnerstag der Fall. Die FTC hat mit drei zu zwei Stimmen einen neuen Vorschlag von Tom Wheeler.
Verabschiedet und veröffentlicht und ja im Endeffekt machen die das nach, was irgendwie die EU-Kommission und auch die Bundesregierung schon vormachen. Jeder sagt, wir schützen die Netzneutralität. Konsequent, es darf kein Internet erster und zweiter Klasse geben.
Bla, bla, bla, Sonntagsrede.
Aber hier erstens zählt Mobilfunk nicht dazu und zweitens Spezialdienste sind ja was ganz eigenes, die ausgenommen werden sollten.
Ja aber wo kommen wir denn da hin? Da würden wir ja unsere Wirtschaft beschneiden und das muss ja alles kompetitiv sein.
Genau, außerdem darf die äh Netzneutralität nur wirtschaftlich angemessen sein. Das habt ihr mit Linus vor drei Wochen oder so.
Ökonomisch war, glaube ich, das Wort.
Ja, ihr habt ökonomisch gesagt, ich habe das mit wirtschaftlich gesagt, was zum.
Angemessen. Genau, jetzt ist der Vorschlag veröffentlicht von der FTC erstmal angenommen.
Steht im Endeffekt genau dasselbe drin, wie auf EU und Bundesebene,
Netzneutralität ist gut, aber gehen trotzdem zur Definition davon habt ihr, glaube ich, schon mal ausführlich mit Thomas Lohninger äh gequatscht, was das Problem an Spezialdiensten ist,
und wer das nochmal in noch ausführlicher haben möchte, Thomas hatte da auch während der in Brüssel war mit Dragon McDonalds von Access Now noch eine Ausgabe vom.
Netpolitik dot EU Podcast aufgenommen, 'ne Folge, da haben die das nochmal in wirklich detailliert für die Policy Nerds unter euch,
ausklamüsert, was das Problem an den Special Life Services ist und wie wenn wir die Schuhe nicht komplett wegkriegen, wenigstens eine sinnvolle Definition aussehen könnte,
dass die nicht uns das Internet wie wir es kennen kaputt machen.
Politiks dot EU ist eine andere Webseite als die du meinst ja den Podcast, ne?
Ja, net dash Politics dot EU, glaube ich. Gut. Genau. Telekom sind gemopet. Das ist.
Weil es gibt auch noch Netzpolitiks ohne Bindestrich, das ist dann nochmal ein bisschen was anderes.
Genau, insofern wollen wir nur darauf hinweisen,
Die FC hat den Vorschlag jetzt veröffentlicht und jetzt gibt's eine sechzigtägige öffentliche Konsultation und schon vor drei Wochen, als das erste Mal durchgelegt ist, wie denn das aussehen könnte, gab's einen Haufen öffentliche Beteiligungen und Feedback und Kampagnenarbeit.
Die haben tatsächlich den Vorschlag vor drei Wochen auch nochmal abgeschwächt und weniger schlimm gemacht. Äh aber es gibt eben trotzdem noch genug Fallstricke da drin, die das freie Internet,
gefährden, nicht nur weil auch wir in Europadienste in den Staaten nutzen und weil wir dann schwerer haben unseren Politikern das zu sagen wie es richtig,
sondern auch durch Sachen wie TTIP, das transatlantische Freihandelsabkommen, was gerade verhandelt wird,
Dadurch könnten die dann durch die Hintertür quasi auch wieder amerikanische Regeln in den europäischen und deutschen Markt kommen,
Also, es gibt jetzt sechzig Tage Zeit, der FC sie zu sagen, was man davon hält.
Und gute Gruppen sind da die äh Open Rides Group, IFF und auch äh.
Viel Lobbyarbeit da zu machen, auch Safety Internet dot com. Äh da kann man mal ein bisschen durchklicken und der FC seine Meinung zu ihrem Vorschlag machen.
Eine letzte kleine Meldung müssen wir noch machen, weil der Linus uns das so aufgetragen hat, auch wenn wir in der Zeit schon mal weiter fortgeschritten sind. Wir müssen über seinen Auftritt im Bundestagsausschuss sprechen. Natürlich in den höchsten Tönen. Oh, habe ich das jetzt öffentlich zitiert.
Ja, Linus ist ja ein äh beliebter Gesprächspartner geworden, zumindest was äh Anhörungen betrifft. Ich weiß nicht, ob mit irgendwie gesprochen wird, aber wird zumindest angehört, also,
ja als Experte Spezialexperte auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, das hat ja schon mehrfach unter Beweis gestellt, äh so auch diesmal. Es ging im tollen.
Bundestagsausschuss digitale Agenda.
Genau, der tolle, der äh tolle neue Bundestags äh Ausschuss, der uns ja,
vor kurzem wird das Beginn dieser Legislaturperiode neu hinzukam und äh der verblühende Landschaften sorgen wird im digitalen Bereich.
Hoffentlich, das bleibt abzuwarten. Hm.
So und worum ging's? Es ging um IT-Sicherheit.
Genau, die Disco, die wollen mal, obwohl die keine Federführung zu irgendeinem Verfahren haben, äh wenigstens mal über alle Themen geredet haben.
Und diesmal haben sie gesagt, machen sie was zu IT-Sicherheit, sich ein paar Spezialexperten eingeladen, unter anderem den lieben Minus Neumann, dem Freund Spezialfreund Sandro Geiken und auch den äh durchaus guten Torsten Schröder, der zufällig auch beim CCC aktiv ist, aber dort äh
seine Firma war und Linus hat mit äh im Namen des CCC Stellungnahme ab
gegeben, wie denn IT-Sicherheit effektiv zu fördern wäre. Und
ja, hast du, hast du's angehört, die Expertenanhörung, das war ein bisschen tricky, weil das genau während der Republik.
Das war wegen der ich ich habe äh ich habe Linus nur auf der Republika noch an diesem Statement hacken sehen, aber ich weiß nicht, bin einfach durch diese Republika komplett in der Glasglocke gelaufen und habe äh diese Anhörung noch nicht, äh wie ist ihnen aufgezeichnet worden.
Äh ich glaube, die ist aufgezeichnet wurde, zumindest wurde ihm das,
hab's mir noch nicht genau angeguckt, wir können ja gleich nochmal nachsuchmaschinen unserer Wahl nach Bingen. Äh aber.
Also PDF ist hier auf jeden Fall zu finden.
Genau, äh der Club hat auch eine Pressemitteilung dazu gemacht, mit dem PDF von Linos. Das ist auch auf der Seiten vom Bundestag. Und er macht halt im Wesentlichen drei Kern
punkte, dass äh
IT-Sicherheit ja wohl nur mit äh Open-Source-Software geht. Ein altes Argument, was wir jetzt, glaube ich, nicht nochmal in aller Ausführlichkeit äh sezieren müssen,
und dass die Bundesregierung und andere städtische Stellen durchaus Möglichkeiten haben und die Qualität von Open Source Software sicherzustellen.
In den Neunziger, Anfang der Nullerjahre, als das damalige, was war das Wirtschaftsministerium, glaube ich, die Entwicklung von Gnu PG
Implementierung des Open PGP Verschlüsselungsstandards ähm gefördert hat und da Geld reingepumpt hat für die Entwicklung,
Das kann man ruhig ausbauen. Auch Backband die es ausschreiben, um so eine Desaster wie Hartbleat und Goetopil von Apple zu vermeiden.
Ja, wenn man von Sicherheit spricht, dann muss natürlich,
auch vollen Internet sollte Dezentralisiert werden, wir hätten von Google zerschlagen, aber auch so zentrale E-Mail-Anbieter, ach E-Mail, aber es gibt ja da auch diese D E-Mail made for Germany oder,
welche Bezeichnungen gerade wieder aktuell ist, wenn jeder seinen eigenen Server hätte, dann wären einzelne Sicherheitsvorfälle bei weitem nicht so äh signifikant, wie wenn einer der großen wird,
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung ausbauen ist sicherlich eine valide Forderung der die man der Bundesregierung immer wieder um die Ohren hauen kann.
Wie man hört, gibt's da wohl auch regierungsinternen ein bisschen Kritik an die Emil, das es ja wirklich mal cool wäre, wenn man das tatsächlich in gut macht.
Wir bleiben gespannt.
Linus kriegt das noch ausgehebelt, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Wir werden, wir werden sehen, ob der Linas die E-Mail kippt. Das kann er dann nächsten Podcast gerne erzählen. Und als letzten Punkt hat er gemacht äh natürlich müssen wir, wenn wir über das Thema IT-Sicherheit reden, auch
den Tyrannosaurus Rex auf Speed im Raum ansprechen. Wir müssen äh Sicherheits und Geheimdienstpolitik äh,
von dem derzeitigen, ja, eigentlich Lazy Fairy tun, was sie wollen, äh Gesetze scheren sie nicht, wie sie teilweise auch selber zugeben. Ähm,
wirklich demokratisch,
kontrollieren äh und unabhängig analysieren und tatsächlich ähm Politik wie in anderen Politikfeldern, tatsächlich auf harten Fakten äh machen und nicht nur auf diffusem Bedrohungs und Sicherheitsgefühl.
Also ein paar Regelungen zur die Geheimdienste an die Kette zu nehmen, sind sicherlich der IT-Sicherheit förderlich. Wir hatten das ausführlich,
ob äh die NSA und die Taylor Access Operation jetzt vorher hatten oder nicht.
Hätten die gar keine Erlaubnis,
zerodays aktiv auszunutzen, sondern eine Verpflichtung, diese den Herstellern zu melden,
dann wäre tatsächlich nicht nur ein paar NSA interne,
Rechner, die davon wussten und die man selber patchen könnte, sondern auch das ganze Internet sicherer als vorher.
Ja, also eine Videoaufzeichnung finde ich jetzt hier so aufm Anhieb nicht nur viele ausgelaufene Links.
Ich bin gestern bei Bundestag DE auch schon mal gefailt mit diesem Argument. Ich dachte, das löck an meinen analen Browser Einstellungen, aber wenn du das hier in deinem modernen Safari auch hast.
Ja, nee, das ist äh
ist schon so ein so ein Drama. Ich habe irgendwann mal angefangen, so einen Link-Checker äh hier laufen zu lassen bei äh Lokbuchnetzpolitik, der so regelmäßig mal schaut, was so an Links dann auch wieder weg stirbt und es halt einfach grade so Bundestag
äh DE äh also auch Parteien generell, also all diese ganzen veröffentlichten PDF und Stellungsnahmen, die wir hier immer mal wieder verlinken, die wechseln dann doch häufig mal ihre äh URLs so ein paar Mal,
ohne richtige, weil sie dann einfach keine Ahnung, entweder haben sie gerade mal ihre Webseite umgestellt, dann sind die ORLs halt einfach, anders oder äh Klassiker immer so, na ja, jetzt ist es gerade in,
aktuell und dann ist es dann irgendwann nur noch in Archiv und dann ändert sich halt die URL auch einfach so aus dem Nichts. Oder diese Stellungnahmen fallen halt auch einfach komplett
äh weg. Also ich habe dann das ein oder andere Dokument dann äh über Aschaff Org äh auch mal äh wiedergefunden und der Google Cash war auch schon mal behilflich und so, aber teilweise ist es mir auch überhaupt nicht gelungen, die äh wieder zu finden. Und das ist schon so ein bisschen
Merkwürdig und ähm.
Publizierung von Bundestagsdokumenten, ist ja krass.
Das bezog sich jetzt konkret vor allem um Stellungnahmen so von CSU und sowas. Da hatte ich das ein paar Mal, also Parteiwebseiten. Ähm ich habe jetzt kein Logbuch äh darüber geführt, was beim Logbuch alles
äh weggefallen ist. Ich bemühe mich einfach regelmäßig, äh die Links zu aktualisieren in den allermeisten Fällen, gelingt mir das auch nur ab und zu,
Aber man könnte sich als Webseitenbetreiber insbesondere beim Bundestag schon noch etwas mehr äh Mühe geben, die Auffindbarkeit von Dokumenten.
Können sie ja auch.
Ja, na ja klar, wahrscheinlich haben nur weniger Admins darauf wirklich äh Zugriff und wir die Öffentlichkeit halt nicht, ne? Es ist äh nur wenige Admins haben Zugriff.
Allen Stellungnahmen der Experten.
So Tim, wir haben heute mal länger gemacht.
Ja. Bisschen, ne, war äh war aber auch erforderlich.
Du hast gesagt, du hast nicht so viel Zeit. Du gehst doch jetzt bestimmt zum Fußball, oder?
Sowas ähnliches. Ich werde auf jeden Fall, aber ich äh bin gerade noch so im Zeitrahmen, deswegen bin ich auch nicht panisch. Nichtsdestotrotz machen wir jetzt mal hier den Sack zu und.
Nächste Woche wieder mit Dinos.
Nächste Woche wieder mit Dinos, wenn nichts dazwischen kommt. Bis bald.
Tschau Internet.